[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
cet après midi sur public sénat pour
suivre le temps fort de la semaine au
sénat les questions au gouvernement à 15
heures les sénateurs vont interroger les
ministres sur les sujets d'actualité du
moment et on va vous faire vivre cet
après midi avec notre équipe de
journalistes est d'abord notre
commentateur situé en tribune de presse
de l'hémicycle du sénat quand un call
mais quand un bonjour quel est le
programme des questions d'actualité
aujourd'hui
bonjour alex on a retenu trois moments
forts à attendre aujourd'hui de ces
questions d'actualité d'abord et bien il
ya le référendum en nouvelle calédonie
avec une date a priori pour le 12
décembre 2021 accord surprise
on va également évoqué aujourd'hui une
bousculade entre des parlementaires de
gauche et des policiers c'était vendredi
dernier ça va être évoquée aujourd'hui
enfin et un dernier thème est originale
et va y avoir comme ça un passage de
relais pour poser des questions en
cascade sur la réforme de la haute
fonction publique on a ce passage de
relais sénatoriales aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle mais on suivra avec
attention
nous serons aussi avec notre interviewer
en salle des conférences du sénat
bonjour steve dont joueur alex bonjour à
tous alors steve quel ministre quel
sénateurs auraient vous à votre micro
cet après midi on aura beaucoup de monde
mais dans quelques instants on sera avec
le sénateur philippe bas on reviendra
avec lui sur ce qu'il convient d'appeler
''l'affaire guillaume pelletier vous
savez cette affaire qui secoue le parti
républicain depuis dimanche dernier alex
est plus à 14h30
nous évoquerons le projet de loi climat
qui est examinée en ce moment au sénat
en commission alors ce texte va-t-il
révolutionner notre manière de consommer
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
entre la sénatrice les républicains
martha 2,6 drac et le sénateur
écologiste thomas d'hossus
[Musique]
mais d'abord on va parler d'économie et
du soutien de l'état aux entreprises
durant cette crise économique le
gouvernement présente aujourd'hui un
budget supplémentaire de 15 milliards
d'euros mais prépare en même temps à la
fin progressive du quoi qu'il en coûte
alors pour en parler j'accueille sur ce
plateau et jérôme bascher sénateurs les
républicains de l'oise bonjour bonjour
les xhosas je précise que vous êtes
également candidat aux élections
départementales dans l'oise et pour des
raisons d'équité on va afficher à la
liste de tous les candidats dans votre
canton je vais en parler à senlis dans
le département de l'oise
je découvre des dents même pas très bien
ce que toi qui aura lieu les 20 et 27
juin prochains j'accueille également le
sénateur socialiste de la sarthe thierry
cozic bonjour bonjour
et puis pour parler de ce sujet des
aides de l'état aux entreprises
nous serons également à distance avec
aurore laluque députée européenne et
membre du mouvement place publique
bonjour bonjour
et puis nous serons également avec eric
delannoy économiste et président du
cabinet tenzing conseil
alors je le disais gouvernement présente
aujourd'hui un budget rectificatif de 15
milliards d'euros pourrait prolonger
encore un peu les aides aux entreprises
durant la fin de cette crise
alors à quoi va servir tout cet argent
les explications de soleil oissel 15 5
milliards d'euros de dettes
supplémentaires vont être octroyés dans
le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif pour 2021 pour les secteurs
les plus touchés par la crise dans le
détail cette enveloppe financera
l'activité partielle les exonérations
des charges pour les entreprises et le
fonds de solidarité jusqu'à fin août
le rapporteur de la commission des
finances au sénat espère que ce montant
sera suffisant
on ne pourra pas se permettre de faire
un nouveau projet de loi de finances
rectificative avant le budget le
gouvernement a usé je dirais même abusé
un peu de crédit qu'il est allé chercher
sur les participations financières de
l'état qu'il avait mis en provision qui
n'ont pas utilisé donc il faut vraiment
pouvoir sortir le plus vite possible
parce que cet amoncellement de milliards
le tournis aux français au total le
gouvernement aura budgété environ 43
milliards d'euros pour ces mesures
d'urgence en 2021
conséquence le déficit public devrait
atteindre 220 milliards d'euros contre
les 173 milliards initialement prévus
par la loi
mais le gouvernement mise sur une forte
accélération de l'activité au second
semestre et sur une croissance à 5%
cette année pour atténuer cet impact
chacun sait que notre économie notre
économie ne peut éternellement vivre
sous perfusion surtout quand l'activité
reprend et qu'elle reprend même fort
dans certains secteurs et il faut s'en
réjouir
nous devons donc nous adapter très
progressivement en faisant en sorte de
continuer à aider encore ceux qui en ont
besoin le fonds de solidarité par
exemple est désormais je le rappelle
accessible aux entreprises quelle que
soit leur perte de chiffre d'affaires
avec le projet de loi de finances
rectificative le gouvernement souhaite
sortir de la stratégie du quoi qu'il en
coûte progressivement la part employeur
du chômage partiel va augmenter durant
l'été les entreprises devront prendre en
charge 15 % du salaire de l'employé en
juillet puis 25% en août jusqu'à
atteindre le seuil normal des 40%
septembre voilà pour ce sujet de soleil
oissel jérôme bascher on le voit il ya
une rallonge budgétaire de 15 milliards
d'euros mais c'est aussi la fin
progressive des aides de l'état avec le
chômage partiel qui va baisser
c'est la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
progressivement c'est une bonne chose
de toute façon il faut que ce soit
progressif ça c'est certain temps qu'il
ya des mesures de restriction il doit y
avoir
accompagnement mais on voit bien que le
gouvernement là tu as joué au pompier
pyromane
il s'est branché les tuyaux de la
dépense publique et des exonérations et
c'était très bien il fallait le faire
nous l'avons soutenu tout au long de
l'année 2020 au sénat simplement comme
un pyromane il a allumé le feu il ne
sait plus l'éteindre c'est le feu de la
dépense publique et des déficits publics
et la dette publique
aujourd'hui ne s'est plus arrêté il est
quand même paradoxal quand cette année
on aura 5 % de croissance
on est suivant les hypothèses du
gouvernement à ce stade je reprends 6
hypothèse un déficit public supérieur à
celui de l'année 2009 est l'année du
commis de l'année du grand confinement
supérieur il ya quand même là un
problème majeur
il faudra quand même bien expliquer un
jour aux français on va en parler de ses
déficits publics qui se creusent
thierry cosy qu'est ce qu'il faut est ce
que c'est le moment de mettre fin à ces
et progressivement à ces aides de l'état
le quoi qu'il en coûte quoi qu'on en
dise a quand même joué les amortisseurs
au sein d' économie française
il fallait qu'il fallait qu'ils soient
amis et qu'il soit mis en oeuvre après
aujourd'hui
moi ce que ce que j'ai plutôt le comte
je fais plutôt le constat que la
capacité à communiquer du gouvernement
est beaucoup plus forte que sa capacité
à anticiper à prévoir et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce plfr témoigne de sept
de ses collègues des finances
rectificative au projet de loi de
finances rectificative témoigne surtout
du manque d'anticipation dans un certain
nombre de domaines la part du
gouvernement on est toujours c'est
toujours au coup par coup l'an dernier
je rappelle de ville de 1,4 tnfr1 sur un
décret d'avancé sur sur le au cours du
premier trimestre maintenant à plfr en
fait on est toujours il ya aucune
anticipation de la part de ce
gouvernement a une forte capacité à
communiquer mais on voit quand même
qu'au final
eh bien on n'avance pas et le bilan est
le bilan qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
c'est quand même l'état de l'économie
française
je rappelle quand même qu'au 31 décembre
2020 il ya près 10 millions de nos
concitoyens qui sont dans des situations
compliquées dont deux millions de
personnes qui ont qui sont en très
grande difficulté c'est encore plus
forte
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un moment je
crois qu'il faut aussi faire des choix
le choix a été fait d'accompagner les
entreprises il fallait le faire et je
crois qu'il aurait fallu aussi avoir une
politique un peu plus ambitieuse et qui
soit à destination de tous les publics
eric delannoy quel est votre avis sur
cette gestion économique durant la crise
du gouvernement sur ce quoi qu'il en
coûte
est-ce qu'il faut y mettre un terme
maintenant et peut-être cibler ces êtres
sur ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin
c'est exactement ce qu'ils vont faire il
faut y mettre un terme maintenant parce
que on doit revenir dans un jeu
concurrentiel et un jeu compétitif
quelqu'un qui sait que les aides
vont plus arrivée va mettre en place ce
qu'il faut pour pouvoir redevenir
compétitif sur le marché saas et
première éléments moi je suis très
surpris des commentaires que je peux en
temps parce que en économie à ce qu'on
appelle justement les antiquités
anticipation qui conduisent à adapter
ses comportements à ce que l'on permet
de projeter est dans une crise comme
celle là donner une perspective unique à
moyen terme empêche d'avoir les
meilleurs compromis comportement à court
terme dont j'ai presque envie de dire
que en termes économiques de pouvoir
s'adapter à des situations
potentiellement en réduisant en
annonçant des déchets ma cour
en termes de réduction de 2 de dépenses
ou long terme de réduction des aides
puis ensuite en s'adaptant par rapport à
la nécessité qui est conduite par la
pandémie que personne ne pouvait prévoir
et compris les variants ça me paraît
être la meilleure manière aujourd'hui
économiquement de ne pas gaspiller
l'argent public
parce que quand on parle de j'ai entendu
deux heures c'était très bien il fallait
le faire
ben c'est parce que c'était très bien il
fallait faire qu'on s'est retrouvés avec
un déficit public comme celui là parce
qu'il ya toujours des décalages entre la
dépense est dissipée cilic on constate
donc je suis toujours un peu surpris de
voir qu'aujourd'hui il y a il ya des
critiques sur quand on voit que le cd
c'est pas c'est pas le gouvernement qui
se dit sceptique comme uniqlo ces deux
dit que c'est quand même le pays la
france qui a le plus on va dire maintenu
les revenus des concitoyens puisqu'on
est à -0 1% quand l'europe en moyenne et
bien au delà de ça et que nous avons
réussi avec une croissance positive au
premier trimestre 2009 21 contre
l'europe est à -0 8 etc
après la moisson refaire des bretelles
de chip on veut viser les notes de
conjoncture de l'insee
bonjour et n'importe quel lieu quelle
fumisterie préparer mieux que n'importe
quel prix pour la reprise qui sera
effectivement d'au moins 500 avant de
donner la parole à aurore laluque une
réaction brève sur le char alors je
crois que vous avez oublié de lire la
note de conjoncture de vendredi 28 qui
explique au premier trimestre 2009 un t1
l'alleud
de notre croissance est négative il est
resté sur les vieux chief c'est dommage
mais c'est très important parce que la
regardez monsieur tu les est ici mon
métier je suis statisticien économiste
de lindsay donc les dates
je les connais par coeur dont vous
n'avez pas de chance mais c'est bien de
raconter des bêtises quand même alors
alors je le dis très sincèrement et mère
très importante au premier trimestre
nous sommes négatifs alors nous n'avons
pas confiné alors que les autres pays
européens ont confiné nous avons confiné
au deuxième trimestre et nous donnerons
aussi les conséquences
on va pas rentrer dans une bataille de
statistiques et de chiffres je voudrais
avoir votre analyse est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ces analyses économiques
est ce que ce quoi qu'il en coûte a eu
des effets bénéfiques sur notre activité
non en fait il fallait faire
effectivement à quoi qu'il en coûte à ya
pas de sujet à ce niveau là on pourra
par contre revenir sur le comment il
fallait le faire
non en fait l'esc est terrible dans
cette histoire c'est que finalement la
sortie du progressive du quoi qu'il en
coûte
et effectivement logique et s doit se
préparer tout comme il faut se préparer
à faire l'inversé jamais il ya un sujet
et si jamais on revient dans une
situation sanitaire problématique faut
être souple en économie après le
problème c'est que c'était cousu de fil
blanc
c'est à dire qu' il était évident que le
gouvernement allait faire du quoi qu'il
en coûte est allé dire ah là là mon dieu
la dette se creuse à dette se creuse va
falloir faire des rêves fin mai les
femmes c'est toujours des réformes
structurelles qui tombent sont les plus
faibles d'entre nous c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'en fait c'est la
manipulation d'arguments pseudo
économique pour faire de la politique
purement politiciennes qui n'est qu'ils
n'aient pas assumé la réalité que l'écho
si ce gouvernement était vraiment
attachés aux finances publiques
dans ce cas déjà les aides aurait été
conditionné premier point l'un à
certaines ont été utilisés pour verser
des dividendes j'ai rien contre les
dividendes que l'argent public en moment
de crise soient utilisés pour ça c'est
inadmissible premier point deuxième fois
on aurait eu un plan de relance avec un
effet le biais là on n'a même pas
d'effets de levier sur ce plan de
relance ensuite on n'aurait pas eu des
coupes dans les impôts si les finances
publiques vous y êtes attaché vous fait
rentrer de l'argent vous ne faites
un plan de relance dans lequel on
supprime une partie des impôts de
production vous ne faites pas une rame
comme il vient de tuer et que j'aurais
pu saluer sincèrement 1 sur les 15
milliards mais dans lequel en fait il ya
encore des exonérations de cotisations
j'insiste sur le terme de cotisation et
non de charge
et puis par ailleurs est là c'est la
députée européenne qui parle on a un
gouvernement qui se dit obsédé par les
finances publiques mais qui sabotent
toutes les négociations fiscales j'en
veux pour preuve encore hier sur la
transparence fiscale qui aurait pu nous
aider à rapporter des milliards dans les
caisses de l'état et où le gouvernement
a pris pour base une note du medef du
medef comme base de négociation et là au
prochain g7
on sait aussi que le gouvernement est
très timide et on attend un taux sans
son annonce réelle sont le taux minimum
effectifs de taxe au niveau mondial joe
biden propose 21 % on sait qu'en
coulisses la france contrairement à ses
grands discours torpille ce type de
négociations dont un moment la france
pourrait prendre position clairement là
dessus je finis là dessus on efface un
gouvernement de poujadisme fiscale et de
clientélisme fiscal à mon sens elle est
bon sauf son fort laluque alors
j'aimerais qu'on parle d'une mesure
concrète dans ce dispositif mis en place
par le gouvernement c'est le prêt
garanti par l'état qui a été beaucoup
utilisé par les entreprises
il ya une partie des sénateurs qui
disent que les entreprises doivent leur
rembourser en cinq ans mais elles vont
et bien être un peu prise à la gorge et
c'est notamment ce que dit le sénateur
centriste pierre antoine lévy qu'on va
retrouver en salle des conférences il
est trahi l'état votre micro aussi
aujourd'hui oui pierre antoine levy
bonjour ses nageurs rds du tarn et
garonne triste union centriste sénateur
union centriste excusez moi vous avez
écrit à bruno le maire pour lui dire
quoi pour lui demander quoi au
gouvernement mais à écouter avec 64 mais
collectionneurs nous avons écrit au
ministre de l'économie pour lui demander
tout simplement de donner une durée
d'amortissement au pge donc aux prêts
garantis par l'état
un petit peu plus longue puisque
aujourd'hui ces cinq ans et non peu je
lui ai demandé avec mes amis sénateurs
de passer un maximum de 10 ans et
pourquoi pas tout simplement parce que à
partir de mars prochain
les prélèvements dont les premiers
remboursements vont commencer à se faire
et
à l'occasion de la rencontre avec le
monde économique notamment sur mon
département chef d'entreprise chambre de
commerce et plusieurs points dallaire
qui ont été signalés c'est à dire que
ces chefs d'entreprise ont peur de pas
pouvoir rembourser pge en tout cas que
ce remboursement sur cinq ans génère un
approvisionnement complète notre
capacité d'investissement futur et donc
ils ont peur de pas pouvoir se
développer à l'avenir ces prêts garantis
palettes par l'état cpe c'est la grande
réussite du gouvernement finalement je
crois qu'avec 40 entre 40 et 50 % des
entreprises françaises qui ont souscrit
exactement ces prix de plus de 700 mille
entreprises plus de 54 milliards d'euros
je crois garantie oui c'est une vraie
réussite aujourd'hui qui a permis
d'ailleurs de sauver des centaines de
milliers d'emplois et des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises
donc il serait vraiment dommage au
moment où l'économie va re on va
repartir
où on arrive à des confiner le pays
finalement d'enlever ces perfusions qui
a permis de sauver l'économie et
finalement de de générer des
défaillances en massive en cascade
puisque la grande inquiétude également
des acteurs économiques c'est de voir
fermer des centaines d'entreprises alors
on pourrait souscrire jusqu'à la fin de
cette année il faudra encore ce
dispositif selon vous
je veux faire une évaluation je pense
que fin d'année déjà sait très bien
qu'il était prolongé jusqu'au 31
décembre pour moi ça mérite une
évaluation à partir du mois de novembre
s'il ya besoin de prolonger il faudra
continuer à le prolonger mais je pense
qu'il est urgent de te permettre société
qui voudrait et allonger la durée parce
que c'est pas une obligation encore une
fois et les sociétés qui ont déjà
utilisé le pge qu'ils ont remboursé les
sociétés qui peuvent avoir envie de
rembourser sur 8 ans 9 ans 10 ans
maximum ce n'est pas une obligation mais
il faut permettre à celles qui sont en
capacité de le faire
de pouvoir amortir sur une durée plus
longue alors toutes ces aides elles ont
un coût qui va payer au final c'est la
fameuse d'être évident
c'était le fameux quoi qu'il en coûte
mais c'était nécessaire pour sauver
l'économie donc aujourd'hui
je pense que nous avons nous avons
franchi un cap avec quand même on a
évité beaucoup de défaillances de
sociétés on le sait chez -30% je crois
de liquidations d'entreprises donc les
fameux quoi qu'il en coûte
là aussi il va falloir petit à petit
retirer les perfusions d'économie pas le
faire brutalement parce que sinon on
pourrait mettre en difficulté grand
nombre de sociétés mais il va falloir
maintenant se poser la question
d'arrêter certaines aides d'en prolonger
d'autres et surtout d'évaluer encore une
fois dans certains secteurs la poursuite
de ces aides
merci pierre antoine les serrures
centriste drôle du tout ses gardes merci
d'avoir installé à mes questions
merci beaucoup steve tirer cozic qu'est
ce que vous en pensez il ya certaines
entreprises qui n'ont pas les moyens de
rembourser en cinq ans ce prêt garanti
par l'état il faut leur donner plus de
temps on peut on peut on peut leur
donner elle aussi un peu plus de temps
je suis super j'y suis pas défavorable
mais par contre je crois qu'il aurait
été aussi important en amont d'anticiper
de mettre un peu de conditionnalité dans
le dans le dense et z aujourd'hui les
services fiscaux font état quand même
d'un dut à hauteur de de près de 50 %
pour certaines entreprises
donc il ya aussi je crois qu'on à l'état
le gouvernement a distribué distribués
aux maintenances intérêts s'interroge de
savoir comment on va faire après je
crois qu'il ya il ya un point important
on sent que on sait que la commande à la
fin la fin des aides va accélérer
la commande la défaillance d'entreprises
qui a estimé qu' dans les prochains mois
en gros il ya dix à vingt mille pm qui
pourrait qu'ils pourraient se retrouver
se retrouver en défaillance donc je
crois qu'il faut aussi être attentif
on a eu la capacité pendant un an et
demi aussi accompagner l'économie on
doit avoir aussi cette capacité à
accompagner des entreprises qui seraient
plus en difficulté eric delannoy est ce
que vous aussi vous craignez et bien
risque de faillites d'entreprises en
septembre si on coupe ces aides trop
brutalement mais en fait il y aura des
faillites d'entreprises parce qu'on ne
peut pas s'il n'est pas normal que dans
une période économique comme la nôtre on
est tout à coup la moitié des
entreprises qu'ils se soient pas en
défaillance par rapport au rythme
habituel à peu près 50 mille
défaillances d'entreprises parents amis
l'autre de 2000 euros près depuis cinq
six ans on est tombé à moins de 30000
depuis depuis depuis deux ans avec la
dette parce que on est super fusion
effectivement ça a été justement dit il
est clair que avec la fin progressive
des aides
on va avoir la fin des certaines ce
qu'on appelle les entreprises sont bi
qui ont vu dans les es dunes un système
d'opportunités qui les a maintenus quoi
qu'il en coûte justement et donc
mécaniquement une fois qu'on va avoir
des un truc des aides qui vont s'arrêter
les entreprises qui n'était déjà pas
viable avant la crise mais qui ont
trouvé dans les haies de la manière de
se perpétuer vont être en défaillance et
on retrouvera les niveaux de
défaillances qu'il y avait avant c'est à
dire qu'on aura un pic de défaillance
dans les deux prochaines années
qui va correspondre à un réalignement
progressif d'une économie qui fonctionne
avec l'axé concurrentiel traditionnels
donc ce n'est pas non plus on peut pas à
la fois dire il n'y a pas de
conditionnalité la conditionnalité voulu
redire il ya un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui n'ont pas droit à des
aides parce qu'elle ne correspond pas
elles ne correspondent pas à des
critères
et puis en même temps empêcher que cette
fameuse entreprise hongrie finissent par
malheureusement vivre la défiance que de
toute façon il aurait vécu
ainsi ce pas la crise qui vont les
mettre dans le mur ce sont des
entreprises qui n'allait pas bien avant
qu'ils continueront malheureusement un
ballet bien parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison que tout à coup on est des
défaillances qui suit alors en tout cas
ya des secteurs qui ont été très touchés
dans cette crise notamment le secteur de
la restauration du tourisme également le
secteur culturel est ce qu'il faut
prévoir
d'autres mécanismes des lacets secteur
jérôme bascher il ya notamment l'idée
d'une baisse de la tva propres à ces
secteurs qui circulent à droite de la
classe politique vous êtes favorable à
une baisse de la tva par exemple dans la
restauration
ça n'avait pas marché ça déjà nicolas
sarkozy à la baisse de la tva et ça
n'avait pas marché je peux vous dire
donc c'est pour ça que les honda était
revenu dessus non il faut plutôt donner
des perspectives claires c'est à dire
que il faut pas aller sur ajouté je
crois que les mécanismes qui ont été mis
en place sont correctes alors peut-être
que dans un certain restaurant parisien
a vu le niveau des loyers pour les
restaurants c'est absolument
ils y sont sur les faillites mais un peu
partout et la vie n'est pas qu'à paris
vu les sommes qui avaient été mises en
place jusqu'à 10000 euros
vous pouviez plus le chômage partiel
faire vivre la plupart du temps votre
pas mettre en sommeil votre restaurant
pour voir leur ouvrir aux jours
meilleurs que nous allons bientôt avoir
nous l'espérons tous
donc il n'y a pas besoin d'en rajouter
ce qui est très intéressant eric
delannoy le disais tout à l'heure il a
tout à fait raison
j'ai tout à l'heure je les reprises sur
la foi mais je lui donnais un point où
il a raison c'est les anticipations
adaptative des entreprises les emplois
aux entreprises elles sont aujourd'hui
absolument besoin d'un cadre clair et
qu'on arrête de leur dire vous avez
peut-être avoir un peu plus de taxes un
peu moins de taxes donc ils veulent des
règles qui ne bouge pas toutes les 5
minutes et c'est ça qui est important et
sur le pge je veux y revenir un instant
parce que jean françois husson à faire
tout à fait le plein air est garantie
par l'état a fait un rapport tout à fait
colossal que je reprendrai après car
quand rapporteur spécial ce sont des
crédits des garanties d'état que je
regarde de près or l'élu qu'est ce que
vous êtes d'accord et ce qu'il faut des
perspectives claires pour les acteurs
économiques ou alors ce qu'il faut
varier certaines aides pour certains
secteurs pour éviter des faillites en
cascade alors il faut des perspectives
claires et les perspectives claires
c'est pas uniquement la question de la
compétitivité c'est surtout la question
d'investissement et la question de la
commande publique
en fait on sait que dans les moments de
crise il ya un acteur qui bouge pas il
ya un hacker qui ne tombe pas
il s'appelle l'état et c'est comme ça
qu'on s'en sort dans les moments de
crise ils voulaient au lieu de faire de
la politique de l'offre de faire des
exonérations de ceci de cela en espérant
que éventuellement ça a un impact sur
l'économie
allons-y directement investissons
profitons-en d'ailleurs pour changer
l'économie parce qu'on aura quelque
chose qui s'appelle la transition
écologique et qu'un petit peu urgent à
mettre en place c'est le moment
justement de faire jouer la commande
publique à plein pour qu'on ait des
carnets de commandes pleins pour les
entreprises
et puis en même temps qu'on en profite
pour réorienter l'économie vers vers
l'écologie c'est toujours un ces moments
de crise qui sont des moments de bascule
où la puissance publique et en force
qu'on peut faire aussi des changements
de modèles sociétaux important il faut
jamais gâcher une bonne crise comme
disait comme disait churchill
alors j'aimerais qu'on parle de nos
comptes publics car tout cet argent du
quoi qu'il en coûte eh bien il a
considérablement dégradé les déficits
publics et si on regarde les prévisions
économiques de 2021 le déficit de l'état
devrait être à 9,4 pour cent la dette
publique à son 17%
ce sont des niveaux historiques
thierry cosy qu est ce qu on a joué avec
le feu avec tout cet argent public
je ne sais pas si on a joué avec le feu
mais aurore laluque le disait didier
précédemment là il faut savoir que les
entreprises du cac40 aujourd'hui ont
généré 140 % de leurs résultats
on dira en dividendes se dire qu'en gros
il ya une partie des aides de l'état qui
a servi ils ont pris dans leur
trésorerie ils sont servis des aides de
l'état pour aller distribuer des
dividendes donc se dire quand même quand
ils existent
il existe des fonds qui peuvent servir
aussi un moment anticipé à permettre
aussi d'accompagner l'économie et
notamment au remboursement de la dette
et sur le conte public sur l'état en
soirée sur l'état mais
sur l'état simple simplement on voit
également que il ya une partie de nos
concitoyens qui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ont généré des la trésorerie
notamment via les parts je crois qu'il
ya de l'argent dans l'économie et donc
là on doit avoir la compagne de la
capacité aussi à un moment de pouvoir
accompagner cette dette
le remboursement de la dette voilà dans
au fil du temps je crois que l'argent
existe il faut aussi que le gouvernement
ait la capacité d'aller le chercher là
où il est jérôme batx est ce qu'il faut
aller
ponctionner l'épargné des français
ponctionner aussi certains dividendes du
cac40 pour rembourser cette dette
c'est un peu compliqué monsieur de la
dette parce que en fait la moitié de la
dette aujourd'hui détenue par des
banques centrales
donc dont 25 % de la dette française est
détenue aujourd'hui par la banque de
france dont l'état est le seul
actionnaire donc si vous il ya un petit
jeu de bonneteau d'ailleurs créé
l'argent et vous êtes l'unique
propriétaire vous prêtez à vous même ce
qui serait interdit dans une société
normale mais ce qui n'est pas interdit
lorsque c'est l'état et une monnaie
nationale donc au sujet de ce n'était
pas le vrai sujet le vrai sujet c'est
qu'on ne s'est pas arrêté là dépenses et
si vous lisez le il ça vient de sortir
aujourd'hui le rapport du haut comité
pour les finances publique présidée par
pierre moscovici il nous dit le déficit
structurel de la france s'accroît et
s'accroît énormément de -5 points
et ça c'est beaucoup plus embêtant c'est
parce qu'on a un problème de conjoncture
que notre déficit est en train de
s'accroître
c'est parce que nous dépensons et nous
dépensons encore plus aux plans de
relance
hors plan de soutien la dépense publique
de l'état augmentent de 60 milliards
entre 2019 et 2021
nous ne savons pas arrêter cette machine
folle il ya 1300 11 mai françois
momboisse entre 1348 371 milliard en
2021 voilà ce que nous dit le haut
comité des finances publiques très
neutre nous sommes en train de dépenser
sans le dire il n'y avait eu des
forfaits avant il ya toujours pas des
forfaits sur les dépenses publiques
non pas pour faire marcher l'économie
mais sur train de vie normale or la uc
est ce que vous pensez que finalement la
crise du corona virus a caché ce
problème d'une dépense publique trop
forte de la part de la france
le problème de le problème c'est que là
le budget de l'état c'est un moyen est
pas une fin en soi
et que dans notre pays on en fait une
finalité en permanence en économie c'est
un moyen ça c'est un premier point le
deuxième point effectivement il ya un
problème disons structurelles alors
qu'on est obsédé depuis 40 ans par le
niveau de dette et déficit public
et pourtant ça continue à augmenter donc
c'est qu'il ya un sujet et le sujet
c'est la qualité des dépenses à mon sens
premièrement c'est à dire que la
politique de l'offre si on fait d
évaluation correcte des politiques
publiques je suis désolé ça ne
fonctionne pas ça n'a pas créé d'emplois
ce n'est pas efficace
ces implications idéologiques ce n'est
pas efficace d'un point de vue
économique digne d'un point de vue de
l'emploi et ça coûte un bras vous fait
de l'employeur en dernier ressort des
territoires sert au chômage et la
garantie de l'emploi comme ils le font
aux etats unis aujourd'hui ça coûte
beaucoup beaucoup moins cher et ensuite
ya un problème de recettes et on doit on
n'arrête pas de faire des coupes des
coupes des coupes et donc au bout d'un
moment où oui effectivement
eh ben on a un un sujet qui est
d'ailleurs à mon avis sur jouer mais on
a un vrai sujet et on a aussi un
problème de dette privée à des coupes
des coupes des coupes en tout cas la
question de la réduction des dépenses
publiques va se poser à la sortie de
cette crise et elle se pose en ce moment
au gouvernement autour de la réforme des
retraites car sa faim ministre souhaite
remettre sur la table
cette réforme des retraites dès la
rentrée de septembre et au public la
ministre du travail lisa bête banque ne
ferme pas la porte à cette réforme
écoutez là je continue à être convaincu
qu'on a besoin d'une réforme de notre
système de retraite
on a aujourd'hui un système avec 42
régime
quelle personne ne comprend rien qui est
par ailleurs un juste donc qu'on ait
besoin d'une réforme pour rendre le
système plus juste et plus lisible je
n'ai pas de doute ensuite vous avez
compris que notre priorité aujourd'hui
c'est la sortie de crise c'est le rebond
notre économie c'est que tout le monde
puisse en bénéficier donc c'est ça notre
actualité du moment je n'ai pas compris
tout pas de réforme des retraites alors
la réforme des retraites on verra ça
veut dire que c'est le président de la
république emmanuel macron qu'il a
tranché cet été la question de la
réforme est habilité région ma chère est
ce que il faut faire des économies et
remettre des réformes structurelles dès
septembre et notamment la réforme des
retraites alors tout d'abord je vais
juste répandre
le fait on fait des coupes dans les
dépenses les impôts on est quand même le
pays qui a le plus de prix en big à
thouars dans le monde dont on n'a quand
même pas fait des milliards d'aidés
coupe enfin pour répondre aux questions
d'efficacité de choses on n'a pas fait
des coupes on est toujours sur les
réformes
non c'est intéressant c'est qu'il rêve
une pour l'instant à l'international a
voté un texte sur la réforme des
retraites ce que c'était que cela qu'ils
aient repris un point qu'on nous le dise
mais en même temps il ya un texte est
voté à l'assemblée nationale qui a été
suspendu on ne dit rien qui croient
encore qu'on va avoir une vraie réforme
des retraites avant l'élection
présidentielle
je pense que si c'était le projet de
faire élire marine le pen alors il faut
faire comme cela eric delannoy vous y
croyez à cette réforme des retraites
remise sur la table à la rentrée on vous
dit qu'il ya une opposition radicale
entre la nécessité économique et la
nécessité politique la nécessité
politique assez d'accord que le moment
aujourd'hui il n'est pas forcément le
meilleur pour remettre cette réforme
indispensable
un jour c'est simple on est en train de
parler de dépendance de vieillissement
de la population de financement de la
dépense à hauteur de 10 milliards on est
en train de se dire que le niveau des
actifs stagne avec une population qui
vit on ne peut pas se dire qu'on va
continuer avec des prélèvements
obligatoires le plus élevé au monde sans
avoir la capacité à faire en sorte que
tout le monde travaille plus le problème
que ça pose c'est de faire en sorte que
l'on puisse travailler plus parce que
c'est pas tellement le sujet d'augmenter
l'âge de la retraite ou de re de faire
la réforme des retraites
quand on sait que dans les entreprises à
partir de 55 ans entre guillemets vous
n'êtes plus personne et vous n'êtes plus
employables dont il ya aussi un vrai
sujet de reconversion qui va être un des
enjeux majeurs en termes de réformes
structurelles
et pour revenir sur les réformes
structurelles qu'on évoquait il ya
effectivement non pas un problème de
niveau de dépenses publiques
c'est un sujet qui est très récurrent et
un problème d'efficacité de la dépense
publique et on voit bien d'ailleurs que
le que la crise du coc id la mirent en
évidence
on a un problème de capacité de décision
de capacité de relire la décision de la
bureaucratie française
on a un problème d'efficacité la dépense
publique c'est auquel il va falloir
s'attaquer en priorité parce que on peut
avoir les niveaux que l'on a là et on
peut s'enorgueillir du fait que ç'a
permis de dresser des inégalités en
france où je rappel contrairement à ce
qu'on veut bien dire les inégalités de
revenus sont les plus faibles ocde en
termes de grâce
un système de retour de distribution ce
qui n'est pas vrai pour les patrimoines
sait mais néanmoins on a un système de
fonctionnement de l'état qui ne va pas
bien et ça il va falloir qu'à un moment
on s'y attelle et c'est pas sur le jeu
budgétaire c'est logique de
fonctionnement qu'il faut revoir et
merci beaucoup eric delannoy c'est la
fin de ce débat merci à tous les cadres
d'avoir été mes invités dans 30 minutes
ce sera l'heure des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement on va vous
faire suivre cette séance avec toute
notre équipe de journalistes avec
notamment un style jourdain en salle des
conférences du sénat et puis quand un
calme et notre commentateur dans la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat
alors quand un qu'elle va être l'un des
sujets forts de cet après midi est bien
à partir de 15h alex on attend au moins
deux questions posées par des présidents
de groupe au premier ministre et on sait
que c'est l'usagé au parlement lorsque
tu un président de groupe qui pose une
question c'est effectivement le premier
ministre et qui lui répond et notamment
les écologistes ils veulent revenir sur
un incident qui a un peu marqué les
esprits c'était vendredi dernier et on
va revoir des images au cours d'une
mobilisation d'agriculteurs bio on a vu
deux parlementaires le sénateur
écologiste joël labbé qu'on va voir sur
les images en noir et également la
députée elle est fille qui s'appelle
bénédicte taurine le sénateur notamment
un qui a été bien peu bousculé qui lui a
même pas un pouce et un cr
et effectivement rien joël labbé qui est
donc le sénateur écologiste du morbihan
a répondu à quelques questions de
publicsenat.fr
il dit être choqués de ce qui s'est
passé vendredi il a bien présenté sa
carte de sénateur pour rejoindre les
agriculteurs qui manifestaient et il dit
ce n'était pas mon but je ne vais pas
envie d'aller à la baston et à propos
des crs il dit j'ai vu des regards
changent et de violence des gens dresser
à la baston et qui n'attendent que ça et
donc on va voir et bien une question sur
ce sujet sur la liberté de mouvement des
parlementaires notamment dans les
manifestations c'est un des moments que
un élément fort que l'on attend
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que et bien en
plus ces manifestations et sculpteur bio
elle continue alex
aujourd'hui ce sont surtout un ces
agriculteurs et dans le bios qui sont
mobilisés comme mai dernier il dénonce
une un projet de réforme de la pac est
donc surtout en matière d'agriculture
biologique alex merci beaucoup quentin
on va continuer à parler des sujets
écologiques puisque le sénat examine en
ce moment le projet de loi climat qui
prévoit des mesures pour une
consommation plus écologique des mesures
comme l'encadrement de la publicité la
fin du polystyrène en 2025 ou encore le
développement du vrac dans les grandes
surfaces alors cette loi va-t-elle
révolutionné notre manière de consommer
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
pour en parler j'accueille martha de
sidrac sénatrice les républicains des
yvelines bonjour et je précise que vous
êtes rapporteur de la loi climat pour la
commune la commission de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable du sénat j'accueille également
thomas dessus bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur écologiste du rhône et je
précise que vous êtes aussi candidat aux
élections régionales en auvergne
une rhône alpes sur la liste écologiste
et donc pour des raisons d'équité
comme avec jérôme bascher tout à l'heure
on va voir la liste de toutes les listes
candidates aux élections régionales en
auvergne rhône-alpes alors avant de
débattre de cette loi climat on va voir
quelles ont été les modifications du
sénat en commission sur ce projet de loi
climat est rasé et résilience on voit ça
avec jordan clan honte et la place du
vrac dont les supermarchés c'est l'un
des points forts de ce projet de loi
climat l'idée est qu'à compter du 1er
janvier 2000 30 les commerces de détail
dont la superficie est supérieure ou
égale à 400 mètres carrés devront
consacrer au moins 20 % de leur surface
au vrac pour atteindre cet objectif
certains points doivent être clarifiées
selon la sénatrice anne catherine
loisier ce qu'on a plutôt c'est
faciliter les modalités d'atteindre ses
20%
il y avait un certain nombre de critères
notamment le nom de référencement le
pourcentage du chiffre d'affaires
nous avons enlevé ses éléments jugeant
qu'il n'était pas opportun pour de
multiples raisons notamment sur les
produits distributeurs pour tenter
d'accélérer ce processus
le projet de loi aborde la question des
emballages l'objectif interdire les
polystyrènes ou polymère dès 2025
une proposition que combien amender la
majorité et l'air du sénat pour la faire
supprimer
parmi les autres points de ce projet de
loi l'article 4 concerne la régulation
de certaines publicités et notamment
celle des produits ayant un impact
excessive sur le climat en mettant en
place un code de bonne conduite dans
l'audiovisuel sur cet article
un amendement du sénat souhaite ajouter
une mention relative aux dangers de la
surconsommation un autre vise à
interdire les publicités qui font la
promotion de la neutralité carbone la
neutralité carbone
c'est un concept qui n'est pas étayé
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
rien n'est véritablement neutre et la
problématique ce que sur un certain
nombre de produits on peut afficher
notre alité carbone en intégrant en fait
uniquement les éléments afférents à la
production dont quelque part c'est une
c'est une infime une information
trompeuse qui qui peut donner bonne
conscience alors qu'en fait le produit
n'est pas neutre d'un point de vue
carbone
ce projet de loi vise aussi à pérenniser
le choix d'un menu végétarien dans les
cantines scolaires
seulement certains sénateurs craignent
que cela n'entraîne un recours accru à
des produits importés leur proposition
prolonger l'expérimentation pendant deux
ans afin de pouvoir mieux évaluer le
système
martha de cidre est que vous avez vous
aussi examiner dans le détail les
mesures de ce texte qui concerne la
consommation et ce qu'elles vont dans le
bon sens et ce qu'elles vont vers dire
notre manière de consommer je n'ai pas
le mot mais vers dire mais oui elles
vont dans le bon sens effectivement je
dirais de toute façon ça va dans le bon
sens et j'ai envie de dire dès lors que
ça va dans le bon sens on prend après le
sujet c'est d'aller de se poser la
question est ce que cela va suffisamment
loin est ce que en allant trop loin est
ce que on
on impact pas un volet social est ce qu
ont un impact pas un volet économique
est ce que l'équilibré est retrouvé au
pas donc ce sont des vrais sujets des
vrais sujets de fond d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle le sénat fait le
choix de faire appel à ces commissions
permanentes en à la fois la nôtre
aménagement du territoire et
développement durable
c'est toujours bon de le rappeler sur le
fond mais aussi nos collègues des
affaires économiques qui ont travaillé
beaucoup avec aussi ce souci puisque moi
j'ai beaucoup échangé avec les
rapporteurs des affaires économiques
avec ce souci social aussi d'un certain
nombre des mesures
oui beaucoup de commissions à du sénat
qui travaille actuellement sur ce projet
de loi climat thomas dessus sur le volet
consommation est ce qu'il est assez
ambitieux ce texte est bien le texte il
est déjà en dessous de ce que proposait
la convention citoyenne est en fait
maintenant quand on parle d'ambition sur
ce texte est très important d'avoir en
tête quelques chiffres il prévoyait
d'atteindre moins 40% des missions à
on est déjà en dessous hélas l europe a
augmenté ce chiffrement 50/50 maintenant
il va falloir rattraper ce retard qu'on
a et sur le volet consommation il ya
plusieurs sujets on l'a vu sur la
publicité sur les produits polluants
la convention citoyenne inclut aussi les
produits consomment par exemple les
énergies fossiles alors que le projet de
loi climat n'a interdit la publicité que
sur les nerfs du fossile donc maintenant
il va falloir avancer aussi sur arrêtez
la publicité sur les véhicules par
exemple qui sont trop consommateurs
notamment parce que il va falloir
arrêter de vendre les véhicules neufs
arrêtez de les vendre assez rapidement
donc il va falloir arrêter d'en faire la
publicité pour pas piéger les gens avec
des plus des véhicules forcément qui
seront interdits plus tard dans
certaines zones par exemple dans les
zones à faibles émissions en ville et
c'est donc pour pas que ce soit punitif
il faut tout de suite commencé à muscler
un peu le volet sur la régulation de la
publicité par exemple un maintien en
parlant de ce sujet de la publicité
vous le disiez en ce projet de loi
interdit la publicité des sur les
énergies fossiles
c'est une bonne idée mal martha de cidre
à quoi est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
c'est une bonne idée
c'est typiquement c'est une mesure qui
va dans le bon sens après nous allons
sans doute en séance à voir le débat est
ce que cela va suffisamment loin au goût
de certains trop loin au goût d'autres
c'est notre débat démocratique qui aura
lieu de manière tout à fait moi je fais
confiance à tous les collègues dans
l'hémicycle chacun évidemment partagera
ses convictions en la matière mais ça va
dans le bon sens d'ailleurs moi même
j'ai demandé cet article là puisque j'ai
notamment complété d'une certaine
manière un article de la loi l'homme
vous savez qui interdit les voitures
polluantes horizon 2030 donc moi je j'ai
avancé la date de la publicité qui
interdirait la vente de ce type de
voiture à 2028 donc vous voyez le sénat
et d'ailleurs c'est un amendement que
nous avons présenté ce matin en
commission et qui a eu l'approbation de
l'ensemble des comptes des commissaires
en fait de l'aménagement du territoire
et développement durable
donc oui et le sénat va essayer
effectivement d'aller plus loin dans ce
débat avec sur la publicité en
amendement que je voudrais citer de la
commission de la culture qui vise à
interdire dès le 1er janvier 2023 les
publicité sur le service public qui font
la promotion des produits ayant un
impact négatif sur l'environnement dès
lors que des produits ont un effet
moindre sur l'environnement et de leur
que ces produits là sont sont
disponibles dès lors qu'il ya des aides
terre native ça c'est un progrès du
sénat c'est un progrès mais on comprend
pas bien pourquoi on s'attaquait aux
services publics et fissa fallait faire
une baisse forcément de recettes à une
concurrence un peu déloyale du service
privé d'un des décédés des chaînes
privées par rapport aux services publics
puisque cet amendement qui a été déposé
par le rapporteur de la commission
culture ne concerne que le service lui
tourne on aimerait que cet amendement
qui va dans le bon sens un rythme un peu
un peu plus lent que ce qu'on voudrait
mais qui va quand même dans le bon sens
ne concerne que le service public et
c'est un peu dommage de faire peser
uniquement ce cette baisse de recettes
sur le service public voilà je martha
déciderait que pourquoi ne pas interdire
la publicité sur ces produits qui sont
un peu polluants sur l'audiovisuel oui
je connais très bien c'était maintenant
puisque j'en ai déposé un identique
également avec michel laugier qui est le
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
culturelles tout simplement parce que
d'abord le service public ce dos se doit
d'être exemplaire j'entends parfaitement
l'argument de notre collègue de sus
c'est évident en revanche il y a quelque
chose aussi qu'il ne faut pas non plus
négliger c'est que les
annonceurs en fait les recettes des
annonces finance aussi le csa qui voit
lui justement devoir évaluer la qualité
des publicités des annonceurs notamment
en termes d'impact environnemental très
négatif aux pas négatif
donc je pense que on entre dans une
démarche tout à fait vertueuse à travers
cet amendement là et je pense que le
sait en tout cas notre conviction que le
service public se doit de montrer
l'exemple et d'être exemplaire en la
matière et donc on va voir un petit peu
comment tout cela va évoluer et de toute
manière où ça va aller aussi dans le
vert le privé à un moment donné c'est un
message fort qui est envoyé 70 du
secteur
c'est un signal fort alors je voudrais
qu'on parle de la question des
emballages et de la pollution des
emballages puisque ce projet de loi vise
à interdire les emballages en
polystyrène en 2025 mais le sénat
devrait revenir sur cette interdiction
ça a été voté en commission
ce serait un recul écologique thomasis
c'est un danger de deux jours délié
d'aidé diluer un peu les textes en
projetant en proposant des objectifs un
peu plus éloignée dans le temps c'est un
peu ce que ce concert les industries le
pousse à chaque fois quand elle n'arrive
pas à bloquer un amendement elle propose
à repousser la date de la mise en
application donc c'est un danger
effectivement là on n'a plus vraiment le
temps en fait de deux de prendre ce
temps pour adapter tout ça puisque on a
eu encore un rapport aujourd'hui de
l'onu qui le dit les trajectoires sont
dramatiques sont nova sur un
réchauffement
5° beaucoup plus rapidement que prévu
donc aujourd'hui il faut prendre des
mesures fortes et borné dans le temps
rapidement on a dix ans pour agir en
gros un donc plus en plus on essaie de
gagner du temps aujourd'hui plus les
mesures seront radicales à prendre
demain donc il vaut mieux prendre les
mesures plus tôt aujourd'hui avec un
délai encore être con con contrat plutôt
que de toujours diluée dans le temps nos
nounous
dawn acision alors pourquoi s'opposer à
cette interdiction du polystyrène en
2025 alors je dirais là on a une très
belle occasion de reparler de la loi
geiq parce que vous savez voilà
anti-gaspillage économie circulaire
puisque dans la loi j'ai qu'on avait
parfaitement identifié ces problèmes là
autour des emballages y compris les
emballages policiers donc en réalité
tout cela était déjà cadré que disait la
loi avec la loi avec dix et on laisse
jusqu'à 2025 les filières et le secteur
la possibilité qu'ils s'organisent pour
nous proposer soit une alternative soit
une recyclabilité de ces produits là et
si en 2025 il n'y arrive pas et que le
compte n'y est pas et bien là on
interdit j'ai envie de dire là on a
donné en fait véritablement la voie à
l'ensemble de nos industriels
est ce que je dis donc ce n'est pas du
tout une suppression si je peux me
permettre ce mois j'ai réécrit je
proposais autre chose sur les
polystyrènes dans ce texte de loi climat
en dix ans bazot ou sur ce que la loi
j'ai qu'a déjà fait en la matière
évaluons le secteur puisque nous les
avons auditionné deux nouveaux dans ce
cadre là tous nous disent mais écoutez
madame la rapporteure nous avons
commencé à investir par rapport à ce que
nous a demandé la loi gec est là on
change les règles tout de suite donc moi
je dis toujours il faudrait qu'on
s'applique quand même une règle qui me
semble fondamental pour qu'on puisse
avancer suffisamment vite de la
stabilité et laisser la possibilité à
tous nos secteurs industriels de
s'organiser eux ils ont très bien
compris ils nous ont dit vous savez on
va peut-être y arriver peut-être pas
mais là au moins pour 2025 on sait à
quoi s'attendre et on sera au rendez
vous on ne le saura pas et là bas on va
leur taper sur les doigts s'ils ne sont
pas au rendez vous donc moi je trouve
que c'est plutôt positif et j'ai
souhaité rappeler quand même tout ce qui
avait déjà été apportées dans le cadre
de la loi geiq
mais oui avoir le temps de s'organiser
c'est ce que demandent les acteurs
économiques et notamment la grande
distribution par rapport à bien au
développement du vrac dans les grandes
surfaces puisque ce texte fixe
l'objectif de 20% de vrac dans les
supermarchés en 2030
il faut des objets des objectifs forts
des obligations pour
inciter le mot l'économie à bouger oui
c'est pas uniquement l'économie c'est
aussi nous on a un le vrac c'est un vrai
changement aussi de lyme pour le pôle
pour le client qui va aller dans les
supermarchés ou dans les grandes
surfaces ou d'autres commerces pour
changer la façon dont on consomme donc
effectivement il faut un peu de temps
d'adaptation il faut aussi qu'on se fixe
un objectif assez ambitieux sinon on n'y
arrivera pas le changement il vient pas
tout seul et sans succès par les zombies
les objectifs rapidement on aura des on
aura des problèmes pour pour la suite et
notamment parce que nos supermarchés
seront pas adapté assez vite et donc il
faut avancer rapidement donc moi je
pense que le vrac c'est un vrai un vrai
levier pour faire baisser le nombre
d'emballages et de suremballage et donc
il faut avancer vite sur ce sujet la loi
pour l'instant est encore un peu timide
martin d'auxy drake 20% de vrac dans les
grandes surfaces en 2030 c'est un bon
objectif
pourquoi pas c'est un bon objectif
d'ailleurs ne revient pas tellement là
dessus en revanche on élargit un tout
petit peu le champ et ça je crois que
c'est quelque chose que le sénat a
apporté dans le cadre de notre
commission et je vois là j'ai souhaité
qu'on élargisse qu'on ne se préoccupe
pas uniquement du vrac dans les grandes
surfaces pourquoi je vous dis ça je
prends un tout petit peu de temps parce
que dès lors que l'on parle de grande
surface même si il ya aussi les moyens
d'un parti 2 400 mètres mètres carrés on
voit bien qu'on est quand même dans un
commerce ont souvent de nous comme
citoyen on prend la voiture pour aller
faire ses courses
donc je trouve qu'à un moment donné ça
me dérangeait d'associer le vrac à
l'encouragement d'une certaine manière
et une consommation en voiture et c'est
la raison aussi entre autres pas
uniquement pour laquelle j'ai souhaité
élargir le vrac aussi pour nos petits
commerces en centre bourg qu'on n'ait
pas l'impression qu'on envoie un message
à nos citoyens en leur disant si vous
voulez acheter en vrac vous allez aller
dans les grandes surfaces et le commerce
du centre bourg vous en trouverez vous
n'en trouverez pas je voulais que le
message soit fois pour dire écoutez le
vrac super mais on y va tous ensemble et
on y va pour tous nos commerces
mais oui il faut valoriser également les
centres bourgs alors on va clore cette
discussion autour du projet de loi
climat on va continuer à en parler dans
les semaines à venir
on va parler d'autres sujets d'actualité
en puisque dans 15 minutes vous
commencez les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et le sujet du jour eh bien
c'est le tour de france qu'a commencé
emmanuel macron avec un déplacement
aujourd'hui dans le lot alors
officiellement c'est pour prendre le
pouls du pays mais certains dénoncent
une campagne présidentielle en tout cas
un début de campagne présidentielle
déguisés pour en parler on va aller en
salle des conférences retrouver steve
jourdain qui enquêtent avec didier
rambaud le sénateur du groupe r des pays
la république en marche de l'isère oui
didier rambaud
bonjour emmanuel macron qui entame
aujourd'hui son tour de france objectif
officiel c'est de prendre le pouls du
pays parce que c'est pas aussi le début
de la campagne présidentielle pour 2022
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est un peu paradoxal qu'on pose cette
question un président de la république
un an avant une élection présidentielle
n'aurait plus le droit de se présenter
deux de se déplacer dans le pays d'aller
dans les territoires je pense qu'au
contraire il entre alors que tous les
autres leaders politiques le fond je
pense qu'il est en train de couteaux de
tordre le cou à toutes celles et ceux
qui pensent que qu'il était une sorte de
président hors sol éloigné des
territoires et en fait il fait la
démonstration ce sera peut-être sur la
vème république le président qui aura vu
le plus grand nombre de français
justement c'est une manière de renouer
avec ce qu'on appelle maintenant les
territoires avec les classes populaires
parce qu'il a accusée parfois d'être le
président des riches
je pense que oui la france de la france
de territoire il la sent il là il la
connaît il a eu l'occasion de s'exprimer
à plusieurs reprises on est dans une
période charnière entre une crise
sanitaire dont il faut sortir et et il
faut retrouver aussi un rebond
économique je pense qu'il a il a besoin
de faire passer des messages dans tous
les territoires auprès de toutes les
corporations possible était aussi
d'écouter encore
le problème des françaises n'auraient
manuel mâcon justement il distille
beaucoup de messages en ce moment des
entretiens des déplacements est-ce qu'il
ya pas un risque de saturation
médiatique selon vous quand on lui
demande comme se rendre en nombre de
sujets quand il ne s'exprime pas en on
se demande mais où est le président
qu'est ce qu'il a à dire donc
donc moi cette surexposition médiatique
de mme choppin au contraire c'est normal
qu'un président de la république doit
pouvoir s'exprimer sur tous les sujets
possibles et dont les français attendent
des réponses et ses tours de france et
être aussi une manière de renouer avec
l'échelon local on critique souvent ce
manque d'implantation locale de votre
parti de savoie palier oui je veux pas
me cacher derrière mon petit doigt ça
aura été durant ce quinquennat un petit
peu le point faible effectivement c'est
un jeune mouvement un politique
on sait qu'il faut une dizaine d'années
pour pouvoir s'implanter dans les
territoires voilà un petit à petit on
fait notre chemin je suis convaincu que
après les élections départementales et
régionales nous aurons un nombre d'élus
supérieur à celui qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui il à venir aux vins dans
votre région emmanuel macron à jules
ignore encore dans les gestes d'israël
oui il est venu il n'y a pas très
longtemps ont visité un centre d'
autiste il ya deux mois donc
donc voilà il a on sera très heureux de
le recevoir à 12
merci beaucoup didier andreau merci
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup et steve thomas dessus
une réaction c'est le début de la
campagne présidentielle de la fin de la
campagne départementale et régionale 2
en marche et on a trois semaines du
premier tour donc y mettre le paquet là
et même de macron utilise sa fonction
présidentielle pour faire campagne
c'est problématique on l'avait vu au
moment du grand débat il a il a utilisé
la démocratie participative ou moins
écoute les coûts des territoires comme
un instrument politique et puis là n'a
rien qu'on est ressorti les milliers de
propositions qui ont été faits dans les
cahiers de doléances on sait pas ce
qu'ils sont devenus
c'est vraiment factice tout ça on est
vraiment dans la dans une démarche
purement électorales martin décidera qui
on reproche souvent emmanuel macron une
sorte de distance vis-à-vis des
territoires notamment des territoires
ruraux
bon ben là il fait un tour de france ils
se déplacent c'est plutôt une bonne
chose et bouger je vais pas vous dire
que c'est une mauvaise chose en tant que
tel c'est toujours intéressant d'écouter
nos élus les territoires moi je dis
simplement qu'il avait
en 2010 est vendu une france mondialisée
il a séduit une frange de notre
population qui était très sensible à ces
thématiques et il a réalisé qu'en fait
la france aussi c'est une france des
territoires une france des élus une
france de la proximité ça c'est quelque
chose qui lui a toujours manqué durant
tout son mandat et comme l'a dit mon
collègue ben on est en campagne
départementale et régionale c'est
curieux non vous trouvez pas qu'il a
maintenant subitement se rapprocher du
territoire et de cette france qui jusque
là étaient ignorées quand même hein ce
n'est pas pour rien qu'on a eu les
mouvements des jets les journées qu'on a
la loi climat d'ailleurs on en avait
parlé tout à l'heure qui est directement
issue de tous ces mouvements là de ce
grand débat qui était une un simulacre
de démocratie permettez-moi de le dire
comme ça puisqu'on sait bien que nous
dans qui sommes des élus locaux
c'est quelque chose que nous pratiquons
au quotidien voilà comme ça c'est dit
alors on va évoquer un mot creux sujet
on va parler à d'espionnage puisque
selon des médias européen des médias
danois les états unis auraient espionné
des responsables politiques européens
notamment la chancelière allemande
angela merkel avec l'aide du danemark et
pour en parler
eh bien on va retrouver en salle des
conférences six jours dans qui est avec
yannick vaugrenard sénatrice sénateurs
pardon socialiste et membre de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement alors qu'on voit l'arrivée
du premier ministre qui entre dans la
salle des conférences du sénat où vous
êtes steve oui monsieur le sénateur
bonjour 20me donc ces responsables
politiques et espionner il ya évidemment
orgue et l'américaine mais aussi des
responsables français emmanuel macron
demande à washington de faire toute la
lumière sur cette affaire
est ce que il vraiment espoir que
washington d'où donne des explications
sur cette affaire selon vous pour
écouter je pense tout d'abord qu'il faut
garder son sang froid parce que chacun
sait que depuis la nuit des temps que
tout le monde nous regarde ce que fait
un peu tout le monde et que même les
amis parfois ont besoin de vérifier que
amis sont toujours des amis s'arrêtant
maintenant mais il faut vérifier
véritablement ce qui s'est fait quoi
qu'il en soit les américains restent nos
amis et nos alliés et nous avons besoin
d'eux notamment sur le théâtre
d'opérations en particulier sur la zone
sahélienne
parmi ses amis et quand même le danemark
le danemark qui aurait donc collaborer
coopérer avec les américains dans cette
affaire ce que le danemark est toujours
un pays ami ya du sujet il ya d'abord le
fait que les américains qui font partie
de l'otan bien nouille bien entendu et
ex pionner espionner le fait que le
danemark qui fait partie l'union
européenne et puis participer ou
collaboré à cela le minimum aurait été
d'informer les membres de l'union
européenne ce qui tout au moins étaient
censés être espionnés bon tout cela va
être mise à plat je pense qu'il faut
relativiser et qu'il faut éviter les
files d'orfraie et garder son sang froid
ce que vous dites un peu c'est que c'est
le jeu des relations internationales
tout le monde est ce que tout le monde
même entre amis c'est un jeu mais
l'histoire nous montre que ça existait
vous savez roosevelt et l'espionné
général de gaulle et wiston churchill
aussi et pour autant il était allié et
même plus qu'à liés au moment d'y aller
et après et puis même si on est amis a
parfois des raisons économiques ihs
qu'ils sont majeurs on sait par exemple
que un jeu la marque elle avait pour
perspective qui est du gaz russe qu'ils
soient clients qui approvisionne
directement mais l'allemand dont les
allemands on peut comprendre et que par
rapport à cela
rapport au gaz que les américains pour
des raisons économiques ne souhaite
exporter le gaz de schiste par exemple
vous avez également sur le plan
économique même si on est amis les
différences d'appréciation et des luttes
économiques importantes lorsque vous
parlez de l'aviation civile entre boeing
et airbus
la même manière au niveau militaire à
des claviers en français rafale et puis
d'autres avions américains donc pas y
aura pas de sanction contre nil danemark
on me contre les états unis ont écouté
nous verrons cela dans quelques semaines
mais je pense que les choses ont
probablement se tasser au fure fil du
temps pour autant il est normal d'avoir
des relations diplomatiques correct et
d'informer autant que faire se peut
c'est jamie de ce que nous faisons ici
ou là merci monsieur le sénateur merci
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup steve on vous retrouve
dans une minute à peu près pour parler
du projet loi antiterroriste avec
philippe bas un projet de loi qui a été
bien examiner l'examen a commencé hier à
l'assemblée nationale
martha décidera que le département votre
département des yvelines était touchée
ces derniers mois par des attentats
terroristes que ce soit à rambouillet ou
à conflans sainte honorine
il faut prendre des mesures
supplémentaires pour endiguer cette
menace terroriste oui moi je crois qu'il
faut faire preuve de fermeté ces et de
clarté dans les objectifs que l'on
s'impose et de fermeté dans les
solutions que l'on va mettre en place et
je pense que là le sujet éminemment
grave éminemment prégnant les yvelines
ont été particulièrement touchés vous
l'avez rappelé ces dernières semaines
donc moi j'attends d'eux
nos collègues députés justement entendre
les messages que qui sont des messages
de nos citoyens et je crois qu'il ne
faut pas que nous fassions preuve de
légèreté et de mollesse sur ce texte là
on va voir ce qu'en pense le sénateur
les républicains de la manche que
philippe bas il est avec steve jourdain
en salle des conférences
oui avec fiba fidba bonjour un jour
projet de loi antiterroriste est
actuellement examiné à l'assemblée
nationale c'est le 20ème texte anti
terroriste en 35 ans qu'est ce que ce
nouveau texte va apporter
il est pas tellement nouveau ce texte en
fait il vient consolider des
dispositions qui ont déjà été prises et
pour lequel d'ailleurs le sénat a de
nouveau voté il ya près d'un an
et donc ce texte aurait pu être discuté
beaucoup plus tôt avant les plus récents
attentats terroristes évidemment la
république doit s'armer dans ses lois
elles soient là doivent former
juridiquement pour faire face au
terrorisme dans le respect de l'état de
droit et là nous avons des dispositions
qui ont été prises en 2017 pour sortir
de l'état d'urgence vous savez qu'on a
eus l'état d'urgence pendant le
septennat au quinquennat de françois
hollande à cause du terrorisme si on
avait pris des mesures très importantes
et nous avions dit au sénat nous voulons
bien prendre des mesures pour la sortie
de l'état d'urgence à condition qu'elle
soit temporaire
il s'agit de les rendre définitive
maintenant qu'elles ont été validés par
le conseil constitutionnel parce que
nous avons la preuve que nous avons
toujours besoin de ces mesures reste ma
tension dans le respect du droit
c'est à dire sous le contrôle du conseil
d'état et du juge des libertés pour
certaines mesures privatives de liberté
vous l'avez dit vous-même l'exception
c'est ce qui devait être qu'une
exception 2015 devient la règle ça vous
inquiète pas pour nos libertés
il ya eu un atterrissage tout de même et
comme je voulais dit le conseil
constitutionnel lui-même
jugée et il est sévère que ces
dispositions par exemple le fait de
pouvoir faire pointer à la gendarmerie
un individu sous surveillance étaient
nécessaires à la lutte contre le
terrorisme et ne mettait pas en péril
nos libertés finalement vous avez vu
l'état d'urgence sanitaire ça a touché
tous les français tout les français ont
vu leur liberté restreinte en matière de
terrorisme
c'est beaucoup plus ponctuelles ce sont
seulement des personnes sous
surveillance et elles peuvent toujours
faire un recours devant un juge qui va
dire si la surveillance qui s'exerce sur
eux est réellement proportionnée et donc
légale ou non et c'est ce à quoi au
sénat nous serons particulièrement
attentifs donner les moyens juridiques
de lutter contre le terrorisme mais dans
le respect de l'état de droit ça c'est
véritablement notre ligne de conduite
bas vous parlez d'appel vous parler
d'état de droit vous parler de
terrorisme vous me tendez la perche
c'est une transition toute trouvée pour
parler de la sphère guillaume pelletier
vous savez le numéro 2 de votre parti
qui propose de créer une cour de sûreté
pour les individus pour les terroristes
sans possibilité d'appel qu'est ce que
cette idée vous inspire je considère que
nous avons là le devoir de lutter contre
le terrorisme dans le respect des
principes fondamentaux de la république
et que nous
pouvons être efficace dans cette lutte
sans avoir à en sortir
ne cédons pas à la surenchère dans ce
domaine par exemple votre collègue bruno
retailleau propose une sortie temporaire
de la cee d âge de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous je crois que cette idée
qui a été discuté déjà il ya quelques
années est là pour eux principal objet
de permettre en réalité de faire
modifier certaines règles dont
l'interprétation a été excessive pour
trouver un bon équilibre dans le respect
des droits fondamentaux
zhang patimo dit aussi qu'il partage les
convictions de robert ménard vous aussi
voulez partager ses convictions et
robert ménard mais si jamais vous dire
évitant absolument les discours de
perdants je crois que est un discours de
perdants un discours qui reposerait sur
l'idée que la droite de gouvernement
serait absente d'un second tour et vous
verrez aux régionales tous les sondages
d'ailleurs en attestent dans toutes les
régions de france
la question est posée en marche par l
air car l air n'est pas en troisième
position à l'air est en première ou en
seconde position et pour l'élection
présidentielle ce sera exactement la
même chose
nous devons nous mobiliser nous pour
avoir un candidat de premier tour
crédible car tous les sondages montrent
qu'au second tour le meilleur candidat
n'est pas macron face au front national
c'est un candidat de la droite de
gouvernement
à nous de fournir aux français la
possibilité d'échapper à cet enfermement
entre l'extrême droite et le maquereau
nice
merci beaucoup je dis bah merci d'avoir
répondu à mes questions retrouve tout de
suite quentin quel mec est en tribune de
presse quentin donnez nous le programme
oui merci steve est effectivement alors
que vous voyez gérard larcher qui est en
train et bien de se déplacer vers
l'hémicycle pour l'arrivée derrière moi
dans un instant dans quelques secondes
effectivement on attend la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
avec la toute première question
consacrée à l'accord surprise entre la
délégation entre les différents membres
de la délégation de nouvelle calédonie
avec un accord sur un troisième un
troisième référendum qui pourrait avoir
lieu en décembre 2021 alors que le
silence se fait derrière - également on
va évoquer la bousculade de
parlementaires de gauche par des
policiers s'étaient vengés dernier on va
également et bien parler de la réforme
de la haute fonction publique la cloche
vient de retentir c'est parti pour cette
séance pas reçu d'observation y'en a
t'il en séance nous n'en voit pas il est
adopté donc le procès-verbal sous les
réserves d'usagé monsieur le premier
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement notre séance et ont
retransmis comme à chaque fois en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
internet
j'appelle ça suit les chacun d'entre
vous a observé au cours de nos échanges
des valeurs essentielles le respect des
uns et des autres mais aussi le respect
du temps de parole et je vais donner la
parole à notre collègue michael
coli mois est ok pour le groupe du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue
le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
pendant plus d'une semaine avec le
ministre d outre-mer sébastien lecornu
vous avez invité plusieurs délégation
calédonienne qui ont également été reçus
par monsieur le président de la
république et monsieur le président du
sénat ces réunions que vous avez
organisé avec monsieur le ministre d
outre-mer et c'est délégation
calédonienne ont permis de dialoguer en
toute sincérité responsabilité sur
l'avenir de la nouvelle calédonie en
effet lors des deux précédents
référendums les calédoniens ont exprimé
clairement leur volonté de rester au
sein de la république française
si cette décision doit nous rassurer
elle implique que plusieurs
responsabilités un ensemble d'éléments
présenté dans un document inédit sur les
conséquences concrètes qu'engendrerait
le oui ou le non
ce travail considérable que je salue a
été réalisée par plusieurs services de
l'état
il témoigne de l'implication du
gouvernement et de l'administration
quelle que soit l'issue choisi par les
calédoniens monsieur le premier ministre
au terme des discussions menées avec
conviction et détermination en
collaboration avec les
on calédoniennes des avancées ont été
obtenues pourriez-vous présenter devant
le sénat les résultats de ces
négociations
par ailleurs si de nombreux doutes sont
levés
d'autres subsistent encore de récents
sondages ont indiqué qu'une partie de la
population calédonienne dont de nombreux
étudiants qui ferait le territoire si le
oui venait à l'emporter
une inquiétude partagée par la
communauté wallisienne et futunienne
possible sur le premier ministre je
souhaiterais savoir quels sont les
assurances que le gouvernement français
serait prêt à garantir à ces populations
je vous remercie pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur coulis mot est ok
je remercie vivement de votre question
qui me donne l'occasion de rendre compte
devant la représentation nationale
devant le sénat en particulier d'une
semaine qui vient de s'écouler et qui a
été effectivement extrêmement importante
d'abord permettez moi de vous le dire
pour le premier ministre qui depuis
michel rocard est toujours chargée d'une
responsabilité particulière dans le
dossier calédonien et dont je me semble
particulièrement investi aux côtés de
monsieur le ministre d outre mer c'était
pour moi la possibilité de rencontrer
physique
r est contrainte oblige la plupart des
représentants venant de nouvelle
calédonie que j'avais invité
nous n'étions pas bien entendu depuis
l'entrée en fonction de ce gouvernement
resté inactif sur ce dossier puisque la
période considérée vous le savez
parfaitement été marquée par
l'organisation du deuxième référendum
prévu par les accords de nouméa
dès les résultats de ce dernier
enregistré le ministre s'est rendu
plusieurs jours là-bas dans l'île pour
ouvrir un processus de concertation et
préparer ce que nous avions prévu c'est
à dire que le moment venu
j'invite l'ensemble des délégations à
venir à paris discuter échanger avec le
gouvernement de la république de la
situation et des perspectives qu'il me
soit également permis le sujet est
important vous le savez monsieur le
sénateur de rappeler au sénat que dans
l'intervalle nous avons eu à gérer des
sujets d'ordre public et je m'en réjouis
qui sont revenus calme et maîtrise et
nous avons eu à gérer le très importants
sujets en lien bien entendu avec les
autorités de l'île et notamment la
présence bac s de lusine du sud
nickel que l'état a concouru par les
moyens qu'il a déployés à régler c'était
vous le savez une affaire de
transmission et donc s'est déroulée
cette séance de concertation très
approfondie et qui prend son terme
aujourd'hui puisque c'est demain matin
que la plupart des repentants qui était
à paris rejoignent le territoire quel
bilan
c'est votre question monsieur le
sénateur pouvons nous tirer de cette
séquence qui s'achève et qui en appelle
d'autres
d'abord et vous l'avez dit je vous en
remercie elle a permis de rappeler la
prime une anse du dialogue et de la
concertation
c'est un des premiers rôles de l'état
veillez à ce que toujours le dialogue et
la concertation s'impose et constitue le
cadre des échanges
si difficile soit-il s'y opposer
puissent être les conceptions que les
uns et les autres ont sur l'avenir de ce
territoire et je ne vous ferais et vient
pas l'injure de vous les rappeler
l'état l'a favorisé létale à
aiguillonner le ministre auquel je veux
rendre hommage s'est beaucoup impliqué
comme bien entendu votre serviteur
deuxièmement la semaine qui s'achève
mesdames et messieurs ce terrain permis
c'était l'un de nos objectifs premiers
de clarifier de manière significative
les enjeux qui sont devant nous vous
avez bien voulu monsieur le sénateur
salué ce travail inédit de l'ensemble
des services administrations de l'état
dans lesquels plusieurs ministres du
gouvernement se sont impliqués quelles
sont les implications du oui et du non
de façon extrêmement détaillée de façon
extrêmement approfondie c'est ce que
nous avons fait qui n'avait jamais été
fait et qui je vous le dis a été très
fortement apprécié par l'ensemble des
participants à ces discussions
essai décisif parce que maintenant on
sait de quoi on parle
en état on est en état de décider en
connaissance de cause deuxièmement cette
j'en profite pour vous dire monsieur le
sénateur qu'il y avait
un atelier spécifique sur wallis et
futuna son avenir et les différentes
conséquences des hypothèses sur les
habitants de wallis et futuna la semaine
qui s'est écoulée a permis d'éclairer
l'avenir autour de trois principes que
je vous rappelle que nous avons
présentée on a discuté
je le dis chacun a pris ses
responsabilités je vais bien l'état a
pris les siennes ne sont pas signer un
accord nous avons mis sur la table après
concertation une méthode
c'était très important d'abord premier
principe l'accord de nouméa doit aller à
son terme
l'état en est le garant c'est respecter
les anciens
côté état mais pour l'ensemble des
protagonistes
quand engager ces processus il y aura
donc un troisième référendum
premier principe qui a été rappelé
deuxième principe ça ne suffit pas c'est
la différence avec les étapes
précédentes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
devons préparer la suite
il y aura référendum mais nous savons 1
que son résultat sera sûrement serré
compte tenu des résultats des deux
consultations précédentes
oui non et après que ce facile que cela
s'il on a éclairés sur les conséquences
je viens de le dire
nous avons mis sur la table une méthode
grâce à laquelle les parties en présence
devront s'accorder pour préparer le jour
d'après nous avons proposé que cette
phase préparatoire s'achève d'ici le 30
juin
2023 et ce calendrier a reçu l'aval de
l'ensemble des parties elle devra a
débouché sur un projet politico
institutionnelle complet que je le
répète la seule réponse oui non ne
permet pas
enfin troisième principe que l'état a
souhaité introduire pardon messieurs ce
sujet très important vous avez raison
madame peut-être madame dépasser les
questions institutionnelles j'ai
souhaité que l'on discute aussi la
question du développement d'un réduction
des inégalités qui sont très forte
hausse et id et que ce sujet au delà des
simples questions institutionnelles soit
au coeur des discussions qui vont
s'ouvrir dans ce cadre mesdames et
messieurs c'est la terre l'état prend
ses responsabilités en décidant de
l'organisation de la troisième
consultation référendaire le 12 décembre
prochain
je vous remercie la parole est au
président patrick kanner pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et république
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le premier ministre mais
si le président pardon d'être aussi dans
le dialogue je ne doute pas un seul
instant monsieur près ministre du fait
que ni de près ni de loin ni
philosophiquement ni politiquement vous
ayez la moindre sympathie pour le front
national
mais au lendemain d'élections
législatives partielles à quelques
semaines aussi le deux rendez vous
électoraux majeurs force est de
constater que l'extrême droite progresse
dans notre pays dans les intentions de
vote dans les médias mais également dans
les esprits aujourd'hui l'hypothèse que
pour une troisième fois à la famille le
pen soit présente au second tour d'une
élection présidentielle devient une
évidence
et encore ce n'est pas le scénario le
plus pessimiste
vous n'êtes pas les seuls responsables
de cette évolution politique mais votre
majorité présidentielle porte depuis
quatre ans le destin du pays
la sombre perspective que je viens
d'évoquer est elle pour vous une
fatalité ou au contraire pensiez vous
utilisez les dix mois prochain pour nous
éviter ce naufrage
monsieur le premier ministre
je ferai plus court monsieur le
président caennais jeu président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je l'ait déjà indiqué à plusieurs
reprises en politique il faut se
déterminer par rapport à soi même et par
rapport à ce qu'on considère être
l'intérêt général du pays
la meilleure façon que des idées autre
que celle que vous représentez ne
parviennent au pouvoir c'est
premièrement de n'avoir pour seule
boussole que les valeurs de la
république de la démocratie et de l'état
de droit
elles sont chevillée au corps de
l'action du gouvernement et du président
de la république
la deuxième c'est devenu une politique
au service de nos concitoyens au service
du redressement économique au service de
la lutte contre la crise sanitaire au
service de la réduction des inégalités y
compris territoriale au service de la
lutte sérieuse opérationnel et non
démagogique contre l'insécurité
voyez vous voyez vous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le pen
en cas nerfs c'est tout à fait ce que
mon gouvernement s'emploie à faire je
vous remercie monsieur le président que
naît
en tout cas monsieur le ministre les
français ne l'entendent pas ainsi
vous nous répondez mesure vous nous
répondez programme de gouvernement
de notre point de vue je vous la corde
c'est effectivement la meilleure façon
peut-être de mener la bataille sur le
terrain pour autant permettez-moi de
m'inquiéter de votre stratégie monsieur
le ministre vous avez choisi votre
adversaire et vous jouer une partition
dangereuse qui peut s'avérer tragiques
pour notre pays
en explosant le paysage démocratique en
promouvant l'ambiguïté du en même temps
en espérant la disparition de la gauche
est maintenant de la droite en méprisant
les corps intermédiaires vous avez créé
un champ de ruines et vous ne tenez pas
compte des avis du parlement et en
particulier de la haute assemblée à cela
vous ajoutez du cynisme sur prêts
ministre vous qui avait été le premier
acteur du vaudeville politique que nous
vivons actuellement en région paca dans
un pitoyable tripatouillage politiciens
le résultat malheureusement le connais
on le voit dans les sondages
vous courez de manière désordonnée après
la thématique sécuritaire et vous avez
également sous-estimé la colère sociale
de nos concitoyens l'exercice du grand
débat n'a pas suffit malheureusement à
les calmer aujourd'hui le danger est à
nos portes
l'extrême droite comme dans d'autres
pays européens peut prendre le pouvoir
sans violence dans moins d'un an le
deuxième tour de la présidentielle sera
passée vous ne pourrez pas dire que vous
ne saviez pas monsieur prémunissent
merci monsieur le président
relais à notre collègue véronique
guillotin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole
le micro monsieur le ministre vous
connaissez la situation si particulière
et si difficile des ressources humaines
en santé sur les territoires frontaliers
et plus particulièrement nord lorrain je
souhaite évoquer ici le phénomène
d'aspiration vers le luxembourg des
infirmières et aides soignantes formés
en france pour en illustrer l'ampleur un
seul exemple l'hôpital de mont saint
martin à quelques kilomètres du
luxembourg
il subit une fuite de 20 % de son
personnel et à ce jour malgré la
fermeture complète d'un étage il manque
encore trente sept infirmières pour
assurer un fonctionnement normal de
l'hôpital fait nouveau les agences
d'intérim n'arrive même plus à suffire à
se fournir suffisamment de personnel
cette situation est devenue tout
simplement insupportable dans tous nos
établissements à l'hôpital comme en
ville les mesures du ségur da santé les
efforts de la région grand est
en matière de formation ne suffiront pas
à eux seuls à stopper l'hémorragie temps
le différentiel salarial entre nos pays
est élevé le premier ministre
luxembourgeois est lui aussi très
sensible à cette question le luxembourg
dépendant grandement des travailleurs
français des solutions monsieur le
ministre doivent être trouvées dans une
dimension transfrontalière
les projets ne manquent pas comme par
exemple celui de créer un institut
transforme alliés transfrontalier de la
formation aux métiers de la santé
alors à quelques semaines de la
conférence intergouvernementale
franco-luxembourgeoise et à quelques
semaines de l'examen du projet de loi
3ds je souhaitais attirer votre
attention sur une situation devenue
impossible
monsieur le ministre c'est quand les
ministres rencontrent leurs homologues
luxembourgeois que les projets avancent
à l'instar de la toute dernière
rencontre entre les premiers ministres
xavier bettel et jean castex sur le
volet par exemple de la mobilité pour
garantir que nos concitoyens en zone
frontalière et accès aux soins dont ils
ont besoin pouvez vous nous assurez
monsieur le ministre de la même
mobilisation pour vous répondre
paroles et aux milices de l'europe des
affaires étrangères la part la sénatrice
véronique guillotin vous avez rappelé
justement que le premier ministre aviez
vettel est le premier mise en cache sexe
s'étaient rencontrés hier pour une
séance de travail dans le contexte
nouveau de la fin de progressive de la
pandémie et je dois dire qu'ils ont pu
observer l'un et l'autre qu'au cours de
cette période
les relations entre la france et
luxembourg s'étaient renforcées dans la
solidarité y compris dans la solidarité
en matière de santé puisque le les hauts
buttés du des hôpitaux du luxembourg ont
accueilli des patients du grand s et que
nous mêmes par nos postes avons permis
le rapatriement de citoyens
luxembourgeois et que n'ont pu maintenir
néanmoins le maintien de la libre
circulation entre nos deux pays et nous
sommes tout à fait déterminés le premier
ministre l'a redit hier monsieur batel
bethel le sommes tout à fait déterminés
à ce que nous soyons dans une logique de
gagnant gagnant
cela passe par une nouvelle dynamique du
co développement
cela passe par des financements
complémentaires de nos voisins
luxembourgeois aux côtés de l'état et
des collectivités frontalière du nord
laura de la région grand est le
financement de projets rendue nécessaire
par l'installation d'entreprises et par
le développement du travail
transfrontalier en particulier dans le
domaine de la santé
et nous avons fait l'inventaire des
sujets qu'il nous faudra aborder lors de
la commission intergouvernementale
franco-luxembourgeoise qui va se réunir
très prochainement c'est à dire avant
l'été et qui ne s'était pas réunie
depuis 2016 et au cours de cette réunion
qui se prépare plutôt bien y compris sur
les sujets vous avez évoqué en matière
de formation de santé
nous aurons l'occasion je suis convaincu
d'enregistrer des nouvelles avancées sur
plusieurs projets structurants je pense
aux particuliers à aux transports
ferroviaires qui permet de limiter le
recours aux voitures et je pense aussi à
la signature de la convention
transfrontalière qui permettra en
matière de santé de développer de
nouvelles pistes de coopération comme
l'amélioration de la formation sur les
métiers en tension et échanges de
stagiaires et la coopération entre
observatoire de santé et laboratoires de
de santé du champ pour joie et avec le
partenariat du chu de metz-thionville
donc tout cela est en cours de
préparation qu'on ce rendez vous qui n'a
pas eu lieu depuis très longtemps et qui
a été activé hier par la visite à paris
du premier ministre avaient vettel
guillotin j'avais quelques secondes
oui monsieur mini j'ai bien entendu je
sais pertinemment qu des choses avancent
je voudrais encore une fois réinsisté
vraiment sur le sujet de la formation
des infirmières et la coopération entre
ces deux pays parce que rien ne pourra
se passer en dehors de cette coopération
et c'est vraiment aujourd'hui sur les
territoires un sujet gravement est un
sujet majeur
merci la parole est maintenant aux
présidents guillaume gontard pour le
groupe écologie solidarité territoire
savez la parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président messieurs
premier ministre jeudi dernier des
paysans désemparé inquiet des
orientations désastreuse de la nouvelle
pac n'avait pas d'autre choix que de
manifester pacifiquement
faute d'être entendus par leur ministre
il demandait simplement une audience au
président des parlementaires sont venus
à leur rencontre pour entamer le
dialogue et tenter de nouer le lien avec
le pouvoir exécutif
résultat des courses notre collègue
bénédicte taurine en écharpe tricolore a
été outrageusement jeté au sol par un
policier
notre cowell collègue joël labbé qui
pourtant avait pris soin d'alerter le
cabinet du président a été empêché de
rejoindre les paysans ces images ont ému
tous les républicains digne de ce nom
monsieur le premier ministre ces faits
de violence contre des manifestants
pacifiques des mairies fait ce temps
pacifiques et contre des parlementaires
identifiés dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions sont sans précédent et
particulièrement grave
votre réponse au président mélenchon
hier à l'assemblée n'est franchement pas
à la hauteur de la gravité des faits
nous vous demandons
aujourd'hui une condamnation sans
équivoque pour vous répondre la parole
et à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président messieurs
sénateurs monsieur président gontard
j'ai effectivement déjà eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer sur ces faits hier devant
l'assemblée nationale
je voudrais d'abord rappeler les faits
tels qu'ils se sont produits ici même
d'abord à me permettant de vous corriger
monsieur le président sur une
affirmation que vous avez fait la porte
du ministre de l'agriculture sur le
sujet de la pac comme sur tous les
autres
et d'ailleurs vous le savez bien sur
tous les bancs du sénat
laporte venise agriculture est ouverte
en permanence à l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales du monde
agricole
ça n'empêche pas l'expression de
désaccord ça s'appelle la démocratie
mais julien de normandie est reconnu par
l'ensemble des communautés paysannes
comme consacrant beaucoup de temps au
dialogue deuxième rectification deuxième
rectification je le porte à la
connaissance du sénat la manifestation à
laquelle vous faites référence en tout
cas pour la partie qui s'est déroulé sur
la voie publique n'avait fait l'objet
d'aucune déclaration au titre de
l'article 211 1 du code de sécurité
intérieure elle s'est poursuivie
elle s'est poursuivie c'est une
constatation par une occupation
totalement illégale des locaux de pôle
emploi dans lequel les manifestants ont
pénétré de force
le gestionnaire des lieux suivant la
procédure légale a fait appel au
concours de la force publique pour
procéder à l'évacuation de ces lieux
dans les formes légales
je le rappelle parce que c'est fait sans
crème extrêmement important les
incidents les incidents dont vous faites
pension se sont déroulées dans ce cadre
là c'est la raison pour laquelle je
redis devant le sénat comme devant
l'international que chacun et en
particulier les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique
les parlementaires bien entendu aussi
les forces sécurité intérieure doivent
respecter les lois de la république
vous le savez sur les faits dont vous
parlez et je n'ai évidemment aucune
information le procureur de la
république territorialement compétent
ces saisies verrons bien les suites
qu'ils donnent mais en toute hypothèse
en toute hypothèse je vous rappelle que
si à bon droit les images dont vous
parlez ont pu choquer et qu'elles sont
regrettables
je rappelle également au sénat que dans
cette affaire
deux policiers ont été blessés et l'un a
subi des jets de pierres qui ont conduit
à son transport à l'hôpital
donc tout cela n'est pas normal tout
cela monsieur le présent n'est pas
normal il y a eu il y a eu des attitudes
qui sont condamnables
j'en profite chaque pour appeler chacun
au calme et à ses responsabilités je le
préviens gontard
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre
jamais une action d'un syndicat
majoritaire pourtant rarement déclarée
en préfecture et je ne compte pas les
les policiers blessés n'a fait l'objet
d'une répression aussi violente et vous
me l'accorderez après les gilet jaune
les journalistes les avocats les
médecins et tant d'autres la répression
violente du mouvement social a atteint
un nouveau paroxysme plus personne
n'était pas renié ni les agriculteurs ni
même les représentants du peuple au
comprends que vous vouliez supprimer les
preuves avec le funeste et heureusement
mort né article 24
monsieur le premier ministre le dialogue
l'écouté la recherche du compromis
voilà les leviers d'une démocratie
apaisée je crois j'ai toujours cru aux
vertus du dialogue social toute la vie
publique en attestent ses mots monsieur
creuser mini ce sont les vôtres
lors de votre déclaration de politique
générale loin très loin de restaurer la
confiance entre l'état et les corps
intermédiaires
vous vous enfermez dans votre tour
d'ivoire le séparatisme n'est pas
toujours là où on croit à défaut de
maintenir au dialogue avec le pays au
cours dû l'empêcher pas de le faire
entrave et les parlements
terre dans l'exercice de leur fonction
est totalement inacceptable
la parole mais mason notre collègue
colette mélot pour le groupe les
indépendants et publie ces territoires
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale chère
collègue la réforme du lycée général
engagé il ya deux ans a remplacé les
filières traditionnelles de la voie
générale par des enseignements de
spécialité choisie à la carte
l'objectif de cette réforme était de
lutter contre les inégalités scolaires
en supprimant le déterminisme social qui
se reflétait dans le choix des filières
les lycéens choisissent désormais trois
enseignements de spécialité en classe de
première pour n'en garder que deux en
classe terminale
or le caractère élitiste reproché à la
filière s se reportent parfois sur le
choix des deux spécialités conserver en
terminale ainsi les meilleurs élèves et
les plus favorisés ont tendance à
reconstituer les filières
traditionnelles de cette façon autre
stéréotype qui n'est pas nouveau 50 %
des filles choisissent d'arrêter la
spécialité mathématiques contre 30 % des
garçons ce choix détermine très souvent
l'orientation post bac pour que cette
réforme atteigne l'objectif visé
certains chefs d'établissements
proposent quelques ajustements qui
pourrait être bienvenue qui s'appuie
notamment sur les questions suivantes
premièrement la préparation des élèves
aux épreuves anticipées de spécialité en
classe de terminale est elle suffisante
deuxièmement le contenu pédagogique des
enseignements science est il toujours en
adéquation avec le nombre d'heures
consacrées qui a diminué après la
réforme
troisièmement l'abandon d'une spécialité
en terminale ne restreint tel pas les
possibilités d'orientation pour un
certain nombre d'élèves
enfin la réintégration de la spécialité
mathématiques au sein du tronc commun ne
permettrait-elle pas d'améliorer le
niveau général des élèves et de réduire
le déterminisme social lié au choix de
cet enseignement
monsieur le ministre quel est votre
regard sur ces questions et plus
généralement quel premier bilan de
l'application de la réforme
dressez vous à ce stade je vous remercie
on vous répondre la parole et obéissent
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports monsieur blanc caire vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice colette mélot merci pour vos
quatre questions en réalité qui est v10
effectivement vont au coeur des enjeux
de de cette réforme
je commencerai par dire qu'il ya un mot
clé dans la réforme qui est celui de
liberté et c'est pourquoi elle est
appréciée des lycéens à chaque fois que
nous faisons des enquêtes d'opinion très
des lycéens c'est autour de 60 % de
satisfaction à ce stade pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont déjà deux premiers bénéfices
notamment la disparition des séries qui
leur permet d'avoir beaucoup plus de
choix
90% des élèves se concentre sur 15
combinaisons ce qui est évidemment
beaucoup plus que les trois combinaisons
antérieures dans la dans la voie
générale
donc on a une philosophie qui est déjà à
l'oeuvre qui donne déjà des effets bien
sûr une autre caractéristique c'est la
modularité et elle est présente dans vos
quatre questions
cette modularité permet une souplesse et
donc des évolutions c'est pourquoi nous
avons un comité de suivi du baccalauréat
qui se tient d'ailleurs le 11 juin
prochain une nouvelle fois pour sans
arrêt adaptés en fonction des situations
que nous voyons alors rapidement comment
répondre à partir de là à vos quatre
questions
premièrement oui le comité de suivi doit
regarder si au mois de mars prochain en
2022 nous devons avoir un programme
légèrement moins ambitieux pour
permettre d'être réellement prêt au
moment d en cdd examens terminaux ça
doit se regarder
sachant que les élèves continuent à
travailler ensuite de mars à juin et que
les gens leur enseignement de spécialité
sont au coeur du grand oral qui l'on a
passé donc ils peuvent faire le
programme complet deuxièmement at on
perdu des heures de science je sais que
ça se dit mais ce n'est pas exact si
vous prenez un état un élève qui prend
le maximum de science aujourd'hui il
arrive jusqu'à 17 heures autrefois en
terminale s il en avait 16
1 ces deux 2 x 6 heures d'enseignement
de spécialités plus trois heures de
maths experte plus deux heures
d'enseignement scientifique dans le
tronc commun donc 17 heures c'est
beaucoup et bien entendu qu'un de nos
soucis a été une de nos priorités a été
de renforcer l'enseignement des sciences
et d'avoir des élèves mieux préparée par
exemple programme de physique chimie est
beaucoup plus ambitieux quand
qu'antérieurement enfin vous vous
demandez si le fait d'abandonner
un enseignement spécialité en première
est un problème à mon avis c'est au
contraire une orientation progressive en
entonnoir et je pense que les élèves
disent leur satisfaction
et tout ceci évidemment est fait pour
être discutées pour les évolutions des
temps à venir jour merci merci mais le
dès maintenant la parole notre collègue
gérard longuet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre parce que
c'est vous cher jean castex qui avait
annoncé d'une façon surprenante dans un
premier temps que vous vouliez supprimer
les préfets et les sous-préfets puis
ensuite vous être avisé pour dire mais
pas du tout c'est le statut que je veux
supprimer
il se trouve que vous êtes énarque aussi
que vous avez servi le président sarkozy
moi aussi que vous êtes membre de la
cour des côtes pas moi mais je suis
membre du corps préfectoral et je puis
vous dire que votre initiative et
destructrice d'un des piliers de la
république sur le terrain pourquoi parce
que le corps préfectoral exige de la
compétence interministériel cela ne
s'improvise pas cela demande de la durée
et lorsqu'il y a duré il y as carrière
et donc statue ensuite le corps
préfectoral cela demande de l'autorité
et cette autorité et les fondée là
encore à l'épreuve des fêtes
cela demande de la durée cela imagine de
la carrière et donc du statut j'ajoute
enfin qu'il faut du sang-froid car on ne
gère pas les expériences très récente de
mes collègues on monte on ne gère pas
l'ordre public comme on gère un exposé
en sortie de sciences politiques il faut
donc de la durée il faut de la carrière
et il faut du statut et avec
désinvolture
vous semblez vous semblez mépriser la
totalité de cette réalité dont vous avez
été bénéficiaire dans la crise des
gilets jaunes dans la crise de la
pandémie et que vous mobiliser
aujourd'hui à ce titre d'ailleurs
et il est bien content de les trouver
sur le plan de relance donc la question
que je pose est d'une grande simplicité
ce corps est ouvert les préfets on peut
nommer n'importe qui d'ailleurs certains
gouvernements ne s'en sont pas privés
les sous-préfets sont ouverts ou de la
minorité d'énarques il y a une immense
majorité de deux magistrats des cadres
de préfectures des policiers
et militaires des voix là encore ouvert
voilà un élément de promotion voilà un
truc qui marche et votre solide et c'est
la poutre en laye
[Applaudissements]
président ns et messieurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gérard longuet je vous ai bien
entendu senti très sincère dans votre
question c'est la mienne aussi
je n'ai jamais dit je commence par là
vous avez débuté que je voulais
supprimer les préfets sous préfets que
jamais je veux au contraire les
renforcer et conforter
vous vous riez vous riez vous considérez
simplement ce président que ça passe par
un statut et par encore d'abord soyons
précis
en plus vous avez parlé des sous-préfets
dans la plupart d'entre eux plupart
d'entre eux les deux tiers des spéciales
et deux tiers
ils sont déjà et depuis longtemps dans
la réforme que nous voulons faire
d'accord tous les deux tiers en question
sont des administrateurs civils
après si détaché dans le corps des sous
préfets bien demain ils seront tous des
administrateurs de l'état
mieux formés et mieux payés compte tenu
des responsabilités qu'ils vont exercer
affectés aux métiers de sous-préfet nous
passons ils auront tous je le précise
les personnes un statut et encore tous
peut être gelé déjà d'ici mais je le
répète
y at il eu une ambiguïté je vois les uns
politisation
soyons très clairs la fonctionnalisation
c'est à dire une gestion des ressources
humaines autour d'une filière et d'un
métier je vais y revenir pour les
questions majeures d'expérience accumulé
que vous avez à fort juste titre relever
c'est tout différent de la
contractualisation
nous le faisons pas ça existe dans 80%
des pays vous le savez bien pas que vous
monsieur l'onglet il ya des pays qui ont
des une haute fonction publique qu'elle
soit préfectoral ou pas qui est
entièrement constitué de contractuels ça
s'appelle le spoil system en bon
français qu'on change
ce n'est pas du tout notre modèle ce
n'est pas du tout vers là où nous allons
je le répète à toutes et à tous
prenaient
je supplie le temps de relire les
travaux préparatoires à l' ordonnance de
préparé par michèle devrait le général
d'ahold je pense que ce ne sont pas des
références insultante
ici ni ailleurs il voulait être assurée
un corps les administrateurs civils le
plus interministériel possible ça
restera ce seront des administrateurs de
l'état qui rendent un des filières la
diplomatie l'administration préfectorale
ou effectivement il ya beaucoup ici
d'élus locaux qui ont occupé des
fonctions exécutives
ça s'appelle des cadres d'emplois à nous
qui l'avons inventé dans lequel on
procède par affectation
on va mieux ils conserveront encore un
statut beaucoup plus interministériel
ise mais je suis pas gêné le corps
préfectoral a déjà largement ouvert la
voie et si j'osais sous le contrôle d'un
ministre je vous dirais même que en fait
cette réforme vise à faire ce qui existe
pour le corps préfectoral qui est sans
doute l'un des plus interministériel est
l'un des plus accueillants entre
guillemets de toute notre haute fonction
publique c'est pas de ceux de l'étendre
à l'ensemble de celles ci en sorte qu'
on va maintenant classé des métiers et
des fonctions
je donne un exemple c'est donner un
exemple mais dans les spectateurs
aujourd'hui avec la logique de corps
vous avancez en fonction de l'ancienneté
et volare vous passez de préfet du gers
à préfet de l'isère
l'isère à la seine-saint-denis bas c'est
comme ça nous pourrions les temples wire
c'est sans intérêt dire mais voilà en ce
moment il ya des gros problèmes en
guyane est infecté un préfet de région à
ce grade aujourd'hui en guyane
c'est absolument nécessaire parce qu'il
ya en guyane une situation sanitaire
gromit très important c'est pas possible
dans la grh actuelle doit considérer que
l'intéressé rétrograde parce que nous
avons une approche statutaire oh non
seulement nous allons conserver les
préfets et sous préfets
bien entendu la république n a plus
besoin mais non seulement nous allons
améliorer leur gestion croyez le bien
croyez le bien mais la vraie question je
l' ai déjà dit ici c'est de renforcer
leurs moyens d'action leurs autorités
d'un état qui sait des membres et autant
territoriale et a dit devant cette
assemblée et c'est ce que nous allons
faire
je vous remercie merci la parole et à
d'autres collègues jean grey pour le
groupe de l'union centriste
[Applaudissements]
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
monsieur le sous-préfet est en tournée
cochez devant lac est derrière la
calèche de la sous-préfecture
l'emportent majestueusement concours
régional de la combo fait sur les genoux
de monsieur le sous-préfet reposent une
grande serviette en chagrin gaufres et
qu'il regarde tristement
et si monsieur le sous préfet regarde si
tristement sa serviette
c'est qu'il sait qu'il va être la
victime collatérale de la crise des
gilet jaune et des errements de
l'administration pendant la période
covin victimes par ricochet monsieur le
sous préfet d'autant plus triste
après vos dernières annonces monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez certainement lu comme
nous la lettre d'alphonse daudet si vous
en avez pris sûrement beaucoup de
plaisir
vous souvenez vous souvenez par donc
emporté par sa passion
le sous préfet faisait des verts je ne
suis pas convaincu qu'après votre
réforme il se contentera de ce la faute
de statut les rats pantoufler hiller
entrera dans le grand mercato des hauts
cadres dirigeants peu à peu l'etat sera
vidée de son armature et de la stabilité
qui fait sa marque
ou alors il faudra que nous acceptions
une autre fonction publique qui
succombent aux chants des sirènes se
sonnant et trébuchant de rémunération
comparables à celles du privé
est ce les prémices d'un système de
dépouilles à la française est ce ainsi
que vous les dessiner la france
le problème n'est pas la qualité du
corps préfectoral mais c'est ce qu'on
attend de lui comme serviteurs d'un
territoire le cadre qu'on lui offre pour
accomplir sa mission
monsieur le premier ministre la france
n'at-elle pas besoin du corps
préfectoral dans un monde rural qui
souffre la france n'at-elle pas besoin
d'un système qui a montré toute son
efficacité depuis 200 ans
la france n'a peut-être pas besoin d'une
école aussi prestigieuses que l'ena pour
attend pour étendre sa zone d'influencé
à l'international
non répondent la parole et à la milice
de la transformation et de la fonction
publique valablement chaleur merci
beaucoup monsieur le président monsieur
le sénateur oui j'ai présenté ce matin
au conseil des ministres une ordonnance
qui réforment l'encadrement supérieur de
l'état
et vous savez ce n'est pas une réforme
de l'ena c'est bien de réforme de l'état
et je voudrais ici rappeler quelques
vérités sur ce que la réforme de l'état
a été depuis quelques quinquennat ça a
été une réforme de l'affaiblissement de
l'état ici sur les bancs de la droite
ceux qui ont défendu la fameuse rgpp on
fait quoi
ils ont vidé les préfectures et les sous
préfectures
ils ont affaiblis ils ont affaibli de
30% les forces vives qui constitue
l'armature réels de ceux et celles qui
s'occupent des français là où ils sont
cette réforme n'a pas été comblé par la
gauche je vous rassure
aujourd'hui nous sommes un gouvernement
qui ne cherche pas à avoir une approche
comptable qui cherche à remettre sur le
terrain des hommes et les femmes
compétents choisi parce qu'ils ont eu du
métier une formation et qu'il réponde
aux besoins des français comme en 45
nous regardons notre pays en face nous
regardons ses faiblesses ses forces ses
défis le monde a changé depuis 45 sur le
numérique sur le climat sur les
technologies nous devons former
autrement recruter autrement
alors je tiens à vous dire une chose le
spoil system que certains décrivent
n'est pas dans nos valeurs parce que moi
autant de mises à la fonction publique
j'assume une chose la boursede c'est de
remettre des fonctionnaires et des hauts
fonctionnaires sur le terrain je suis la
première ministre de la fonction
publique depuis 15 ans avoir remis dans
les départements des hommes et les
femmes
deux hauts fonctionnaires se sont
enrichis préfet à la relance vous les
avez critiqué
voilà ensuite j'assume aussi j'assume
aussi messieurs et mesdames de défendre
le statut de la fonction publique parce
que j'entends des anciens ministres
certains mes prédécesseurs de la droite
tout simplement appeler à la
ban a bazardé le statut la fonction
publique plus ça tu connais contrat et
donc c'est ce que nous choisissons pas
de faire enfin j'assume autre chose
j'assume que nous devons toujours face
aux logiques de corps préférer les
compétences les métiers et les personnes
je vous remercie
je suis un grès vous avez quelques
secondes de la ministre j'étais rassuré
par une chose suite à l'intervention du
ministre longuet je pensais que ça
faisait que votre réforme avait été
construite sans la participation des
nerfs mais suite à l'intervention du
sénateur longuet j'avais oublié que le
premier ministre avait été marqué donc
je pense que c'est une raison de plus
pour défendre les n'a ainsi que le corps
préfectoral
merci je vais la parole maintenant notre
collègue à petit aux pourceaux police
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologistes avaient la parole
mais si un collègue monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
décidément le courant ne passe plus
entre les usagers et les compteurs linky
depuis son déploiement en marche forcée
de réelle résistance se sont exprimés et
aujourd'hui les usagers apprennent
qu'ils devraient finalement remboursé
les compteurs linky
ces compteurs qui pourrait permettre à
des acteurs privés puisque le projet
hercules renommée grande déesse prévoit
la privatisation du gestionnaire de
réseau est né dix d'effacer voire de
coûts
coupez
il faut
être réaffirmé
soyons clairs en 2011 le ministre besson
nous disait line qui sera gratuit en
2018 c'est le ministère de l'écologie
qui confirmait cette gratuité et depuis
le gouvernement n'a eu de cesse de le
répéter il n'y aura pas d'augmentation
de la facture liée à linky gratuité de
l'installation et pas d'augmentation des
taxes ni du tarif de l'électricité
et pourtant il semble bien que les
usagers et les collectivités locales
dont les factures ont flambé de 50% en
10 ans pourrait encore débourser près de
130 euros par compteur si on ajoute que
la goutte durée de vie des compteurs
n'est que de 20 ans il faudra donc
remettre la main à la poche sous peu
enfin malgré les démentis des nedis le
turpe 6 c'est à dire les taxes inclus
dans les facture augmentera bien au 1er
août
ma demande est simple monsieur le
ministre à madame la ministre
allez-vous respecter les engagements
pris auprès de nos concitoyens d'une
gratuité totale sans entourloupe des
compteurs linky
mais surtout allez vous mettre enfin
être plus transparence sur les coûts
réels que devront supporter les usagers
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est au volant bureau gérard
secrétaire d'état chargé de la
biodiversité
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice apourceau poly alors vous nous
interroger et vous vous interrogez sur
cette supposée
affirmations relayées par la presse
relative à une augmentation des factures
d'électricité qui seraient liées au
remboursement de l'installation des
compteurs linky
je vous confirme cette installation elle
a eu un coût un cookie estimé dans le
rapport de la cour des comptes à 130
euros par part compteur ce coût
d'investissement
il est et il sera directement et
intégralement supportée par l'entreprise
genedis entreprises qui le recouvre par
des économies d'exploitation dans les
prochaines années avec un réseau plus
moderne un réseau plus flexible qui
permettra à la fois des économies pour
pour le réseau et pour les consommateurs
il n'y aura donc pas comme cela a pu
être avancé d'augmentation de 15 euros
ou d'un autre montant sur la facture
annuelle d'électricité qui seraient
liées au remboursement de cette
installation de deux compteurs au delà
des économies d'énergie qui sont rendus
possibles par ce compteur linky ce sont
aussi des économies sur le budget des
ménages sur les budgets personnels vous
le savez grâce à une meilleure maîtrise
de nos consommations
nous participons donc avec cette offre à
la possible fourniture de contrats plus
adapté à nos à nos consommations nous
avons un meilleur regard sur ce que des
appareils énergivores ou d amélioration
de la performance énergétique nous
permettent d'économiser à la fin comme
ressources en termes d'énergie mais
aussi sur nos sur nos budgets avec donc
des gains sur la facture d'électricité
liée à ces fonctionnalités de linky ce
déploiement
il est observé il est suivi très
régulièrement vous le savez également
par la creux la commission de régulation
de l'énergie qui a elle-même surveiller
et estimé le bon fonctionnement de ce
marché
sa cohérence avec nos objectifs de
politique énergétique pas d'augmentation
donc pour les consommateurs la creule a
redit les économies associées au
déploiement de ces compteurs linky
elles compensent les coûts
d'investissements et donc nous serons
très attentifs et vous le serez j'en
suis sûr a comparé les factures et je
suis sûr que nous pourrons
collectivement nous réjouir de ce bon
fonctionnement
mesdames vos arguments ne sont
absolument pas convaincu il faut des
actes forts et le premier d'entre eux
doit être de renoncer à la privatisation
des nets d'is au projet hercules devenu
grand edf
seul le nom change mais pas votre
volonté de casser cette entreprise il
faut aujourd'hui résister madame aux
adoptions européenne dont les compteurs
linky sont un avant-goût libéral bien
amer merci la parole est maintenant
madame la présidente catherine de roche
pour le groupe est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
va porter sur l'udc 6 le conseil
stratégique des industries de santé qui
se tiendra fin juin le dernier date de
2018 et le premier ministre de l'époque
s'était engagé à redonner à la france
une des premières places en termes
d'innovation place qu'elle perdait au
fil du temps alors certes des
engagements étaient tenus mais des
freins demeurent il y a le problème bien
sûr l'innovation mais aussi l'ural
problème de la souveraineté en termes de
médicaments et notamment pour des
médicaments matures alors notre
commission a lancé une mission flash
praxis d'un vernis guyotat et annie dame
encore police selon les rapporteurs et
donneront leurs conclusions avant le 6
mai je souhaitais savoir dans quel état
d'esprit vous abordez ce que si ce
monsieur le ministre est notamment à
l'aune de la crise sanitaire pour vous
répondre la parole ou secrétaire d'état
en charge des enfants et les familles
monsieur avrillas cac et vous avez la
parole merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs madame la présidente des
roches vous connaissez bien ces sujets
vous connaissez le rôle également du
conseil stratégique des industries de
santé cette instance de dialogue qui a
été instaurée en 2004
placée sous l'égide du premier ministre
et du président de la république ce lieu
de concertation et des changes auxquels
le gouvernement est particulièrement
attachée parce que le dialogue qui s'y
tient a en effet toujours permis aux
pouvoirs publics de mieux comprendre les
contraintes les enjeux les ambitions
également l'industrie les produits de
santé et puis aux industriels
al'inverse de percevoir les exigences
des différentes politiques publiques que
nous menons et c'est cette compréhension
mutuelle qui fait la force de cet
exercice est donc de notre de notre
système de santé par la crise sanitaire
a d'ailleurs mis en exergue dans un
contexte global d'augmentations de
tensions d'approvisionnement auxquels
nous avons été confrontés la nécessité
de garantir la sécurité sanitaire de la
france et donc de se doter d'outils pour
assurer l'accès sur le territoire aux
traitements dont les passions besoin le
look 6 y participent pleinement à leurs
ce conseil a pour ambition de consolider
la place de la france comme nation
innovantes et souveraine en santé avec
cinq axes stratégiques qui ont été fixés
que je vous rappelle dans cette
perspective assurer une recherche
fondamentale d'excellence et
interdisciplinaire catalyser
ovation en aidant les jeunes entreprises
innovantes faciliter l'accès au marché
des produits innovants soutenir
l'industrialisation des produits voir la
relocalisation qui a été un échec nous
avons beaucoup évoqué ces derniers mois
et enfin développer et faire émerger les
formations nécessaires à disposer des
compétences avec toujours comme seul
objectif évidemment d'offrir aux
patients un meilleur traitement et leur
garantir un accès dans la durée alors
vous le savez probablement un travail a
été mené par cinq personnalités
qualifiées sur ces cinq axes de travail
approche de son terme et des annonces
pourraient intervenir d'ici l'été le
ministre des solidarités a conscience
des attentes que ces travaux ont initié
la politique industrielle et
l'innovation au service du patient ont
trop souvent été opposé dans notre pays
nous ne partageons pas cette vision nous
souhaitons une industrie forte une
industrie créatrice de valeur pour les
patients et le système de santé français
et je sais que ce soit est largement
partagée karl qu'il participe à la fois
la meilleure sécurité sanitaire de notre
pays mais aussi à la souveraineté que
vous évoquez dans votre dans votre
question à laquelle nous sommes là aussi
tout s'est tu achètes de roche oui en
effet fixé les objectifs que l'on
partage maintenant nous verrons quelles
sont les annonces du xi sait comment ça
se traduira dans les faits en effet les
attentes elles sont nombreuses et à tout
l'écosystème de la recherche et à le
développement des filières il ya les
essais cliniques précoces notamment avec
le point très particulier des comités de
protection des personnes et puis il ya
une réforme de l'évaluation que l'on
attend toujours et je n'oublie pas bien
sur le financement la stratégie
industrielle elle est majeure elle est
quasi inexistante dans ce domaine
actuellement et donc vous dire que notre
commission suivra comme le lait sur le
feu je puis dire les suites données oxis
nous le verrons lors de comment ça sera
dur à dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ou
lors de tests que nous avons déposé des
propositions de loi sur la médecine
personnalisée ou sur les cpp et puis
dans le cas de la présidence européenne
le président larcher a fixé un axe est
un thème pour nos travaux qui est celui
de la stratégie européenne met notamment
en matière de santé
en matière de recherche et il faut faire
confiance à nos chercheurs anneaux à nos
industriels aux thérapeutes il faut les
aider et non pas les freiner il faut
savoir prendre des paris faire des
risques
et gare à faire des paris et brand des
risques et j'espère que vous serez tenir
compte des enseignements de la crise
sanitaire et faire un vrai retour
d'expérience merci madame la présidente
[Applaudissements]
la parole au questeur jean pierre sueur
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
de dca merci monsieur le président
madame amélie de montchalin vous engagez
vous au nom du gouvernement à ce que l'
ordonnance qui a été adopté ce matin sur
la haute fonction publique donne lieu à
une ratification explicite au terme d'un
vrai débat parlementaire je vous
remercie
la parole est à la ministe la
transformation de la fonction publique
madame de montchanin
monsieur le sénateur d'abord vous savez
une ordonnance est toujours prise parce
que le parlement à habileté gouvernement
à le faire vous l'avez fait parce que
dans le cas de la loi d'août 2010 9
l'article 59 a habilité le gouvernement
a présenté une ordonnance dans les
délais jusqu'au 7 juin qui doit ensuite
être déposé sur le bureau des assemblées
d'ici au 7 septembre et ensuite dans le
cadre des prérogatives à la fois du
gouvernement et du dialogue avec les
présidences des assemblées du sénat
définir un ordre du jour qui posera le
cas de la ratification mais j'aimerais
vous dire monsieur le sénateur qu'il ya
là une réforme qu'il faut regarder comme
une réforme qui n'est pas une réforme de
suppression ni de destruction qui se
fait au grand jour qui se fait sans
agenda caché et qui je crois est le
fruit d'un long travail de droite de
gauche et sur ses bancs de discussions
qui ont souvent eu lieu et qui ont
rarement abouti
alors nous sommes prêts tout à fait aux
débats je me suis tenue est d'ailleurs
la disposition et c'était à ma demande
de la commission des lois et de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
vous y étiez présent la semaine dernière
notre réforme et l'art pour que nous
puissions regarder trois faiblesses
parce qu'il n'est en rien question
d'insuffisance des hommes et des femmes
de grande qualité qui se sont battus et
qui ont fait que l'état tienne mais nous
voyons bien que sur la diversité sur
l'ouverture sur la proximité
rappelons nous quand même que 90% des
hauts fonctionnaires
ce travail à l'intérieur du périphérique
alors que 90% des fonctionnaires sont
répartis dans le pays
nous voyons bien aussi un déficit de
d'efficacité sur des sujets comme le
numérique le climat qui pensent
aujourd'hui que c'est la seule
responsabilité par exemple d'une liste à
la transition écologique
il nous faut donc former différemment
recruter différemment gérer les
carrières différemment le faire au grand
jour le faire pour les français parce
que les hauts fonctionnaires
n'appartiennent à personne à aucun parti
politique
ils appartiennent à l'état et donc à la
nation tout entière je vous remercie
monsieur le questeur cheveux
tant que
[Musique]
madame la ministre vous savez bien que
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question
simple et précise que j'ai posée vous
n'ignorez pas non plus la décision du
conseil constitutionnel du 28 mai 2020
donc nous n'avons aucune assurance que
ce qui est la mise en cause de l'état
républicain tel qu'il a été conçu par
jean zay par le général de gaulle par
michel debré par pierre mendès-france
nous avons aucune garantie que cela ne
reviendra pas que cela reviendra devant
le sénat et devant l'assemblée nationale
il est inconcevable qu'on fasse cela
sans que le parlement puisse s'exprimer
ce n'est pas acceptable madame la mine
10 alors voilà vous voulez j'ai écrit un
seul mot sur mon papier parce que je ne
veux pas me tromper fonctionnalisation
alors quelle richesse complémentaires
pour la langue française
nous allons avoir des préfets
fonctionnalisés monsieur le drian il est
parti mais des diplomates fonctionnarisé
des fonctionnalités nous allons avoir
des corps d'inspection qui n'auront plus
l'indépendance nécessaire pour exercer
leur mission tout cela madame n'est pas
sérieux et n'est pas conforme à l'esprit
républicain
j'avais donné la parole maintenant notre
collègue edouard courtial pour le groupe
l'est républicain le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le garde des sceaux monsieur le
ministre
chaque jour apporte son lot de violence
elle est dorénavant partout aucun
territoire n'était pas renié elle touche
tous les citoyens et c'est nouveau
si plus particulièrement ce qui
représente l'autorité
c'est le cas des élus locaux au premier
rang desquels les maires victimes de
violence verbale est de plus en plus
physique comme il ya quelques jours
encore en côte d'or nous ne le dirons
jamais assez agressé un maire ou un élu
s'est attaqué la république ceux qui
sont au service des autres deviennent
donc une cible
cette banalisation et cette impunité
sont intolérables pour nos concitoyens
la lassitude se dispute à l'impuissance
car l'état semble avoir perdu le
contrôle de la situation
depuis le début du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron les coups et les
blessures volontaires ont augmenté de
près de 20% malgré le confinement bilan
sans appel pour mettre fin à cette
spirale dangereuse il n'y a qu'une seule
réponse possible et vous le savez tous
la fermeté à lorsque l'on regarde par
exemple ce qu'il est advenu des
agresseurs d'élus nous sommes loin du
compte et c'est révoltant dans l'isère
un maire frappé au visage et brûlé à une
main a vu ses agresseurs condamné à une
peine de prison avec sursis et quelques
travaux d'intérêt général dans les
yvelines
un maire dont l'agression s'est traduite
par cinq jours d'itt et et a vu ses
agresseurs condamné à 200 et 300 euros
damende dans le pas de calais un maire
agressé violemment qui a été hospitalisé
a vu ses trois agresseurs écopé d'un
avertissement solennel et d'une peine
assortie d'un sursis
pensez vous monsieur le ministre que ces
peines qui évite toute incarcération
soit la hauteur de la gravité du délit
commis
pensez vous que c'est ainsi que nous
protègerons vraiment nos élus il ya donc
d'un côté les beaux discours et de
l'autre la triste réalité d'un côté
l'intransigeance de façade et l'autre la
complaisance coupable
monsieur le ministre vous vous indignez
vous
rendez hommage mais je vous le dis pour
les mères ce n'est plus suffisant
ne pensez vous pas qu'il est temps
d'abroger les lois et les circulaires
belloubet qui font tout pour éviter la
prison c'est à dire une vraie peine aux
voyous je vous réponds de la parole et à
monsieur le garde des sceaux soucieux du
pur moretti pour reprendre un mot
monsieur le président qui a été utilisée
ici dans cette enceinte
il ya de ça quelques séances je devrais
monsieur le sénateur pratiquement avoir
honte parce que vous lorsque vous étiez
au pouvoir
vous avez réglé toutes ces questions de
délinquance vous allez me permettre
d'abord un aparté si vous le voulez bien
depuis une trentaine d'années c'est
environ environ 1000 crimes de sang dans
notre pays peuplé de 65 millions
d'habitants
aller voir ce qui se passe à l'étranger
je vais très très vite je les dis je les
dis c'est un aparté c'est à dire que
nous avons un meurtre un crime de sang
voyez trois crimes de sang par jour donc
la filière elle est inépuisable pour
vous et vous pouvez le regarder la
justice que sous une analyse fait
diversier r la question et qu'avez-vous
fait que proposez-vous sur les élus je
vais vous répondre parce que nous avons
fait beaucoup de choses voyez-vous dès
le 7 septembre où était le 7 septembre
2020 en concertation avec les
associations d'élus et certains d'entre
vous le savent j'ai signé des
instructions claires et précises
savez vous que entre 2019 et 2020 nous
avons doublé le nombre de condamnations
sur ce champ infractionnel savez vous
savez vous que le taux d'incarcération
d'emprisonnement s'élève en 2020 à 62%
il est en hausse de près de 10 points
via une circulaire du 15 décembre 2020
j'ai demandé la mise en oeuvre de la
justice de proximité justice de
proximité que nous avons mis en place et
j'ai encouragé un dialogue avec les élus
locaux
vous devez savoir monsieur le sénateur
que dans votre département
allez donc les rencontres et les
parquets de bové senlis et compiègne ont
mis en place un certain nombre de choses
qui n'existaient pas et notamment
ferrand parquet qui est à la disposition
bien sûr des élus mise en place dans les
trois parcs et de votre département
signature d'un protocole entre les
maires et les parcs et déjà signée par
près de 60 communes de votre département
réunions régulières avec les maires du
département
je l'avais indiqué madame la présidente
gatel j'ai demandé à créer un dispositif
qui n'existaient pas aujourd'hui j'ai
sollicité le mois dernier que via les
services judiciaires nous obtenions une
remontée semestrielle des violences et
les parquets que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure comme tous les parquets de
france d'ailleurs demande aux forces de
l'ordre
immédiatement d'être informés pourquoi
sanctionner j'ai terminé monsieur le
président merci merci la parole est
maintenant madame catherine morin
desailly c'est le gros jeu l'union
centriste
ah non
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président au moment où un
nouveau scandale éclate sur l'espionnage
des dirigeants européens à parrainer ça
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire et
porte sur les incohérences du
gouvernement vis-à-vis des gars femmes
qui sont aussi le bras armé de la
puissance américaine
en europe la protection des données
santé des français rsa cet égard notre
préoccupation en juillet ici même
monsieur le ministre je m'étonnais que
ce soit microsoft qui étaient chargés
d'héberger leurs plateaux mais c'est
sans appel d'offres spécifiques
le secrétaire d'état au numérique me
répondait alors au mépris des acteurs
technologiques européens que c'était la
meilleure et la seule société
le président de dassault systèmes sont
était ému et avait rappelé emmanuel
macron qu'il avait acquis une des plus
importantes sociétés mondiales de
traitement des données de santé
medidata et qu'il n'avait même pas été
approché depuis on a découvert que
plusieurs millions des serveurs de
microsoft soit disant incontournables
ont été espionnés par la chine partout
sur la planète et pendant des mois comme
l'a révélé élise lucet l'architecturé la
plateforme a par ailleurs été conçu par
le responsable du plus gros revendeurs
de données médicales au monde
la société américaine y cuit ya alors
maintenant que pensez de votre annonce
le 17 mai dernier d'une nouvelle
stratégie point cloud dit de confiance
incitant des sociétés françaises à
utiliser les technologies dégâts femmes
pour traiter nos données les plus
sensibles
donnant ainsi un blanc sa dé microsoft
ou google pour entrer dans le saint des
saints de nos administrations au moment
même où la commission européenne lance
une enquête sur les usages d'amazon et
microsoft par les institutions
européennes
assumez-vous vraiment ses choix qui met
encore plus en péril notre sécurité et
surtout torpille nos propres aux
entreprises pour vous répondre la parole
et à la secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'économie sociale solidaire
olivia grégoire il avait la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice morand
de zazie merci de votre question oui
le cloud est partout il est devenu un
outil absolument incontournable pour
héberger traité comme vous le savez il
avait rappelé les deux
des entreprises des administrations des
citoyens c'est une opportunité cet essor
du cloud pour la france et pour l'europe
il représentait vous l'avez aussi bien
mentionné des risques intégrité des
données multiplication des cyberattaques
nous en parlions la semaine passée
menace des législations
extraterritoriale donnant accès à nos
données aux états étrangers par exemple
pour répondre rapidement à ces enjeux et
vous l'avez mentionné aussi le
gouvernement élaboré une stratégie
claire en trois piliers le label cloud
de confiance qui rend possible de
nouvelles combinaisons comme la création
d'entreprise qui allie actionnariat
européen et technologies étrangères sous
licence et va permettre aux entreprises
et administrations françaises de
bénéficier de meilleurs services
offertes par le cloud tout en assurant
la meilleure protection pour leurs
données par ailleurs la politique cloud
au centre qui est porté par la ministre
amélie de montchalin au coeur de
l'administration pour accélérer
résolument la transformation numérique
manipulant les données sensibles qui
devra impérativement être hébergées sur
cloud interne de l'état ou sur un cloud
industriel validées par l'anssi
enfin une stratégie industrielle
ambitieuse inscrits dans le pays à 3,4
et de france relance qui va permettre
d'asseoir la souveraineté française et
européenne en la matière sur le sujet
précis du lda club que vous mentionnez
madame la sénatrice
sachez que dans les délais annoncés par
olivier ferrand c'est à dire au plus
tard fin 2022
nous garantissons la migration vers un
cloud de confiance labellisé donc c'est
une garantie que nous vous apportons
voici en un mot les priorités de la
politique de cloud du gouvernement bruno
le maire mais aussi amélie de montchanin
et cédric haut et l'ensemble du
gouvernement ils sont pleinement engagés
et précisément sur le sujet duel data
club je vous remercie de celui de
secrétaire d'état
je regrette vraiment cette complaisance
dangereuse vis à vis de sociétés qui
prétendent créer des technologies
protectrice en accordant de coûteuses
licences à des acteurs européens pour
des offres de cloud made in europe
elles ne seront en aucun cas soyons
lucides protectrice vis-à-vis de la loi
fillon qui perd le service du
renseignement américain de tenir
secrètement les données traitées par des
sociétés américaines où qu'elles soient
c'est d'ailleurs cette loi qui a
justifié l'annulation de l'accord
transatlantique de transfert des données
par la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
cette stratégie je vous le dis et à
contre temps elle ne pourra donc pas
vraiment répondre aux enjeux de
souveraineté numérique contrairement à
ce qu'a affirmé cédric au hélas mes
chers collègues force est de constater
que la gaffe a misé à sion de l'état est
en marche
la parole est vaste on ne peut coller
catherine procaccia pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
concerne les difficultés que rencontrent
les habitants de plusieurs communes
devant département pour établir des
procurations pour les élections de juin
jusqu'à présent dans les villes où il
n'y avait ni poste de police nationale
ni tribunal d'instance
il leur suffisait de se rendre au poste
de police municipale les jours où la
police nationale assurer ses permanences
et d'enregistrer leur procuration
il en a toujours été ainsi en
particulier à villeneuve le roi et à
blon mais aujourd'hui la police refuse
de les enregistrer
elle n'en a plus le droit contactée la
préfecture qui a défini l'an passé les
lieux indique qu'elle a reçu par
circulaire de votre part la consigne
stricte de ne pas permettre le dépôt de
procuration et poste de police
municipale
pourtant le décret du 1er juin 2020 dit
bien que les électeurs peut se faire
établir des procurations dans un lieu
recevant le public autre que le
commissariat ou au tribunal d'instance
pourquoi interdire aux policiers
municipaux d'exercer cette fonction
monsieur ou madame amélie je ne sais pas
qui je crois que c'est madame la
ministre qui me répond pouvez-vous
comment pouvez-vous declan et inciter
les français à voter et en même temps
supprimer les yeux dans le kent où se
déroulent des ray ban auriez vous un peu
comme à l'image d'un ancien président
des états unis peu trop de procurations
soit défavorable à vos candidats ma
question est double pourquoi c'est
interdit et comptez vous revenir sur
l'arrêté de la préfecture du val de
marne et et d'autres départements qui
interdisent ces locaux auparavant
utilisés
la parole est à la bénisse délégué en
charge de citoyenneté madame arlette
chabot merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice catherine procaccia
d'abord pour répondre à la fin de votre
question nous n'avons peur de rien et
certainement pas de la démocratie au
contraire nous avons eu des débats sur
ces bancs pour pour indiquer les dates
des prochaines élections et donc le 20
et 27 juin se tiendront ces élections
dans un contexte pandémique particulier
que chacun connaît et vous savez nous
avons ensemble pu enrichir ce projet de
loi sur les élections départementales et
régionales pour faire en sorte que ces
mesures sanitaires existe et donc ce que
je veux vous dire c'est que la politique
du gouvernement elle vise à mettre en
place la plus grande les conditions la
plus grande participation possible
notamment avec la procuration
concernant le sujet plus précis des
policiers nationaux
vous avez une collègue qui m'a posé une
question sur le sénateur si ça j'étais
en train de vous répondre madame la
sénatrice en vous disant que sur le
sujet des policiers nationaux en
permanence occasionnels dans les
services de police municipale est
lesquels nos registres pas les
procurations ça s'inscrit dans une
démarche constante qui va dans le sens
d'un allègement de la charge des agents
dans le contexte sanitaire que chacun
connaît nous voulons vraiment les agents
de la police nationale puis se recentrer
sur leur métier et c'est le sens de
cette consigne qui a été donnée mais
pour autant nous ne réduisons pas les
lieux où les procurations peuvent être
enregistrés je veux le dire très
clairement les commissariats de police
nationale demeure disponible pour faire
valider des documents dans le cadre
d'une procédure qui allège cette charge
et s'agissant des personnes qui ont des
raisons objectives de ne pas pouvoir se
déplacer maladie handicap autres et dans
les services de police continue partout
sur le territoire d'assurer la
prestation de déplacement à domicile et
puis enfin il ya ce site n'a procuration
point gouv.fr qui permet à chacun de
faire à la majeure partie des démarches
en ligne pour réduire justement les
délais d'attentes dans les commissariats
je voudrais à cette occasion remercier
l'ensemble des élus l'ensemble des
électeurs qui se mobilisent à chaque
scrutin pour tenir les bureaux de vote
et qui participe également suite au
dépouillement
ils font vivre la démocratie c'est un
rôle essentiel et soyez assurés madame
la sénatrice de la détermination du
gouvernement aux côtés des élus aux
côtés des assesseurs des bénévoles des
électeurs pour faire en sorte que ces
élections se tiennent dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et avec
la plus grande participation possible je
vous remercie
alain progressium oui donc effectivement
on voulait supprimer un certain nombre
de lieux et en même temps vous dites
vouloir favoriser les élections en même
temps on fait un texte de loi sur les
polices municipales et en même temps on
interdit dorénavant la police nationale
qui exercent dans ces lieux de pouvoir
faire leur métier
vous dites vouloir lutter contre le
climat et en même temps vous en plo vous
obliger les gens à prendre leur voiture
pour se déplacer un certain nombre de
kilomètres pour moi ce quinquennat c'est
sont les incohérences dans le même temps
en permanence et la communication la
parole à notre collègue jean jacques
michau pour le veau socialistes
écologistes et républicains
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
l'annoncé soudaine en mai dernier du
report de la réorganisation d'edf dit
projet hercules est venu siffler la fin
de la partie d'une affaire bien mal
entamée entre menace de privatisation
démantèlement de ce géant de
l'électricité et désarroi des salariés
ce plan n'aura finalement pas fait long
feu et c'est amiens
aujourd'hui encore nous n'avons aucune
information sur les raisons qui ont
conduit à l'échec de ses négociations
avec bruxelles
quels sont les points d'achoppement
quelles contraintes n'ont pu être levé
n'en savons rien
ce manque de transparence auquel vous
nous habituer pose un véritable problème
démocratique
beaucoup se demande d'ailleurs s'il ne
s'agit pas là d'une de vos habiletés
pour permettre au chef de l'état dans
jamais l'élection présidentielle sans
subir les contrecoups d'une réforme très
contestée
madame la ministre la france possède
avec edf
l'un des plus grands groupes
énergétiques européens intégrer le
premier opérateur nucléaire du monde
pourtant ce germe publics ne cessent de
pâtir de choix désastreux réalisés dans
le passé des décisions qui sous prétexte
d'ouverture des marchés ont conduit edf
à vendre à perte à ses concurrents au
rang desquels de grands groupes
énergétiques l'électricité qu'ils
produisent de plus comme l'admettait il
y à peu monsieur le ministre bruno le
maire
une telle réforme ne peut se faire
contre le corps social d'une entreprise
cette scission porterait un coup
fatal à notre grand opérateur public qui
a pourtant un rôle majeur à jouer dans
la transition énergétique
face à l'urgence climatique et qui dès
lors devrait être confortée à nouveau le
chemin que dessine le gouvernement est
encore trop floues et ne répond pas pour
l'heure aux interrogations de fond qui
pose sur le groupe
madame la ministre voici donc mes
questions pouvez vous nous confirmer qu
edf restera bien un groupe intégré non
soumis au morcellement
comment sortir de l'impasse de
l'endettement pour sécuriser le
nucléaire et continuer à investir dans
les énergies renouvelables
quid de la préservation du parc
hydroélectrique français si chère à nos
territoires
il est grand temps madame le ministre de
nous donner une feuille de route claire
et un calendrier précis
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et la secrétaire d'état en charge
de l'économie sociale solidaire et
responsable à la mode et vieillards igor
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur michaud votre question porte
sur les projets industriels stratégiques
d'edf et son rôle clé dans la transition
énergétique mais aussi sur la
transparence du gouvernement sur ce
dossier très stratégique vous le savez
le gouvernement en lien étroit avec edf
bien entendu à engager des discussions
avec la commission européenne pour
mettre en oeuvre une réforme ambitieuse
de cette entreprise stratégique nous
sommes de votre avis je reprends votre
mousse est parce qu edf est un très
grand groupe
c'est en ce nom c'est pour le pérenniser
le rendre plus fort que nous souhaitons
mettre en oeuvre une réforme ambitieuse
cette réforme doit sécuriser edf sur le
long terme
nous sommes encore à cette heure en
pleine négociation cette réforme doit
aussi sécuriser la place que nous
donnons au nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique la reconnaissance que
l'activité nucléaire n'est pas une
activité comme les autres et justifie la
mise en oeuvre d'une régulation
cette réforme doit enfin ancrer
durablement edf comme entreprise
publique mais aussi sécuriser les
concessions hydroélectriques et enfin
garantir le statut des industries et les
trick et gazières les yeux j'ai ainsi
bien entendu que de leur personnel
soyons très clairs premièrement monsieur
le sénateur michaud cette réforme est
nécessaire dans l'intérêt du groupe edf
deuxièmement le gouvernement est une
ligne rouge clair très clair le maintien
d'un groupe edf intégrer totalement
intégrée avec cette réforme c'est
l'objet de discussions et ça veut dire
en un mot que nous n'accepterons pas un
accord qui conduirait à l'éclatement du
groupe j'espère être aussi claire et
transparente que possible et répondre
ainsi à votre questionnement des
consultations sont aussi en cours
évidemment avec les syndicats pour
améliorer le projet crée consensus
autour de cette réforme et rien ne
s'oppose à ce que le parlement se
saisisse du débat sur l'avenir du df si
ce projet de réforme aboutit je vous
remercie et espère avoir répondu en
transparence à votre questionnement
pendant le même temps notre collègue
jean pierre vogel pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question concerne le projet
de loi portant lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique examiné
aujourd'hui même en commission
elle s'adressait au ministre de
l'intérieur dont je regrette l'absence
puisqu'il connaît bien dans son
département les problématiques sur
lesquelles porte ma question
ce texte climat représenterait je cite
la ministre de la transition écologique
un changement de société en attendant il
faut bien constater l'omission d'un
problème majeur concret grave est
pourtant lié au climat en effet pas un
mot sur un phénomène qui touche pourtant
de nombreux départements dont celui de
la sarthe celui des sols argileux qui se
rétracte après des épisodes récurrents
de fortes précipitations suivi de
sécheresse les maires des communes
concernées sont extrêmement isolées dans
leurs démarches auprès des services de
l'état pour obtenir la reconnaissance de
l'état de catastrophe naturelle tenus
par des délais contraints ne sachant pas
pourquoi la commune voisine aura été
reconnue est pas la leur impuissant à
aider leurs administrés rien non plus
dans ce texte soit disant de rupture sur
le régime d'indemnisation des
propriétaires dont les maisons fissurées
les contraignent à déménager ou à
supporter de couteau travaux quand ils
en ont les moyens je partage avec de
nombreux collègues sur tous les bancs de
cet hémicycle mon grand étonnement de ne
rien voir à ce sujet dans le projet de
loi climat madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous dire si le gouvernement
a enfin pris la mesure de la situation
en acceptant la réforme proposée par le
sénat pour vous répondre
paroles elles sont la milice délégué en
charge de la citoyenneté j'avais la
parole mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur jean
pierre vogel je vous réponds sur cette
question absolument fondamental
l'indemnisation des dégâts provoqués par
les épisodes de sécheresse elle est
aujourd'hui assurée vous le savez par la
garantie catastrophe naturelle et c'est
sa mise en oeuvre qui a conduit le
gouvernement à reconnaître si 1974
commune en état de catastrophe naturelle
au titre des épisodes de sécheresse
géotechnique des années 2018 et 2019
ça représente une commune française sur
cinq cependant la reconnaissance de
l'état de catastrophe naturelle
elle n'est prononcée que lorsque les
épisodes de sécheresse géotechnique
présente une intensité anormale avérés
et ce au regard des critères
hydrométéorologiques et géotechniques
amélioré en 2019
il ya ce dispositif des aides
exceptionnelles destinées aux
particuliers qui habitent dans les
communes n'ont reconnu dans l'état de
catastrophe naturelle au titre de la
sécheresse 2018 qui a été adoptée en est
la fille 2020 et au terme du travail
gouvernemental approfondies notamment la
loi vous avez évoqué les modalités de
mise en oeuvre de ce dispositif qui ont
été définies par décret seront modifiés
dans les tout prochains jours afin
notamment d'assouplir les conditions de
ressources des sinistrés pour qu'ils
puissent bénéficier du dispositif
d'élargir les dépenses éligibles au
dispositif pour couvrir par exemple les
frais d'assistance à maîtrise d'ouvragé
les mesures conservatoires réalisé dans
l'urgence souvent par les propriétaires
et le gouvernement a soutenu la
proposition de loi adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale le 28 janvier dernier
destiné à moderniser le régime de la
garantie de catastrophe naturelle c'est
un texte qui contient des dispositions
importantes visant à améliorer la prise
en compte de ce phénomène
et puis pour finir afin d'enrichir la
réflexion notamment que les
parlementaires sur ce sujet vous savez
que le gouvernement a missionné
l'inspection générale des finances et le
conseil général de l'environnement et du
développement durable pour proposer des
mesures concrètes d'amélioration de la
prévention de la prise en charge des
dommages provoqués sur le bâti existant
par la sécheresse géotechnique les
propositions de la mission vous nous
permettre de nourrir le projet de
réforme du régime
de la garantie catastrophe naturelle
pour qu'il réponde et qui couvrent
vraiment y compris l'ensemble des
limites du dispositif actuel
vous voyez comme vous le gouvernement
est pleinement mobilisée sur ce sujet
d'importance qui dépasse les clivages et
ils s'appuient sur le travail constant
des préfets en lien avec les maires
confrontés à des effets concrets de ces
phénomènes sur les territoires et
notamment sartre comme vous l'avez
mentionné je vous remercie monsieur au
gel madame la ministre
il n'est plus temps d'attendre des
conclusions d'un rapport commandé par le
gouvernement à des inspecteurs de
l'administration
alors que tout a déjà été formulée dans
le rapport vaspart bonne foi de 2019
la proposition de loi que vous évoquez
qui a été adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale le 28 janvier dernier fait des
propositions très nettement
insuffisantes au regard des enjeux et le
gouvernement le sait bien il est plus
que temps de réformer un régime
d'indemnisation des catastrophes
naturelles dont tout le monde s'accorde
à dire qu'il est devenu largement
obsolètes les nombreux propriétaires
sinistrés les maires concernés attendent
de l'aide des réponses concrètes et
tangibles et non des incantations la
parole à notre collègue marie pierre
richet pour le groupe l'est républicain
ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
j'associe à mes questions catherine de
roche présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales la période estivale
propice aux échanges arrivent avec des
rassemblements familiaux et amicaux des
événements culturels ou des loisirs
quels moyens comptez-vous mettre en
place en termes de dépistage pour
assurer que les td confiné se passera
dans des conditions de vigilance
optimale et éviter une quatrième vague à
la rentrée allez vous remobiliser les
officines de pharmacie pour encourager
notamment les autotests recommandé par
la haute autorité de santé pour des
pistaches itératif qu'en est il de la
capacité des entreprises et des
collectivités a proposé des autotests ou
des tests rapides à leurs collaborateurs
de plus quelle anticipation peut-on
espérer pour préparer la rentrée
scolaire et enfin on nous annonce sur
nos territoires
une baisse des doses de vaccin je pense
aux pays de la loi par exemple avec les
doses de files heures alors que les
communes du littoral vont voir leur
population croître fortement durant
l'été est-ce confirmé pour nous répondre
à la parole et au secrétaire d'état
serbe lui enfant et de la famille
monsieur adria taquet merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice marie pier richer permettez
moi tout d'abord de peut-être percevoir
dans votre question le voeu que nous
partageons tous celui de l'essai très
prochainement derrière nous cette crise
sanitaire qui met notre pays à rude
épreuve depuis plus d'un an avec
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur
sanitaire le gouvernement travaille
évidemment pour que cette perspective se
réaliser les chiffres récents sont
encourageants je me permet de les
partager avec la représentation
nationale vous les connaissez je les
rappelle moins de dix nouvelles dix
mille nouveaux cas recensés en moyenne
chaque jour soit un niveau comparable à
celui de la fin du iième confinement une
pression hospitalière qui diminue
nettement avec moins de 3000 personnes
dans les services de réanimation
nous sommes bien évidemment pas encore
revenue une situation normale mais ces
chiffres valident je le crois la
stratégie
gouvernement dans matière de lutte
contre l'épidémie mais nous pouvons
également nous satisfaire du succès
notre campagne de vaccination depuis le
début vous le savez ce sont plus de 26
millions de nos concitoyens qui ont reçu
une première dose soit à ce jour 50 % de
la population majeure de notre pays le
rythme quotidien aussi entre 500 1000 et
700000 injection et avec une vaccination
qui est désormais ouverte à tous les
adultes quel que soit leur état de santé
et des annonces seront très
prochainement faite par le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé olivier véran
sur les prochaines étapes de cette
stratégie et notamment pour les semaines
à venir et les mois estivaux nous devons
rester vigilants évidemment totale du
gouvernement le rappelait encore tout à
l'heure à sortie du conseil des
ministres il y à des régions où fameux
air où les taux d'incidence a pu
augmenter ces derniers jours donc
vigilance évidemment de nous tous encore
respect des gestes barrières et
poursuite de la campagne de vaccination
large et massive notamment à l'attention
des plus fragiles en priorité comme
c'est le cas de la stratégie du
gouvernement depuis le début c'est bien
ce à quoi nous travaillons avec le
développement notamment sur le
territoire d'une stratégie d'aller vers
les populations les plus isolées les
plus fragiles un conseil de défense
sanitaire a eu lieu ce matin pour
aborder la question de la vaccination
des adolescentes plus de 12 ans vous le
savez probablement l'agencé européenne
du médicament a donné son accord la
semaine dernière à à l'inde et à l'inde
et à l'inde et des vaccins et là aussi
la haute autorité de santé va bientôt
rendre un rapport et le ministre aura
l'occasion de s'exprimer prochainement
sur cette question là les officines de
pharmacie enfin pour conclure ont été
des acteurs centraux jusqu'à présent et
elle le demeureront encore dans les
semaines à venir jour mais ce que marie
pier richer monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie pour vos réponses mais ça ne
répond pas aux trois quarts de mes
questions ce qui montre bien que les
questions sont encore nombreuses éxilé
en était encore besoin le manque de
lisibilité sinon de visible
était dans nos concitoyens c'est que les
professionnels pâtissent est bien
présent ces interrogations induisent des
doutes et donc de la méfiance là où une
faute au contraire de la confiance
s'il est indéniable je vous rejoins que
l'accélération au tas de la vaccination
a permis nette amélioration de la
situation sanitaire il ne faudrait pas
que le déconfinement de cet été que nous
avons tous appelés de nos yeux se
termine mal je tiens à saluer ici
l'engagement de nos élus sans lesquels
les centres de vaccination je le
rappelle n'aurait pas été efficient
monsieur ministre plus que jamais la
carte des décisions doit être exigeante
pour être efficace merci merci monsieur
le premier ministre deux messieurs les
ministres nos prochaines questions
d'actualité au gouvernement auront lieu
le 9 juin à 15 heures la séance est
suspendue
elle sera reprise à 16h45 pour le débat
sur le bilan de l'application des lois
la séance est donc suspendu voilà pour
ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
intégralité et en exclusivité sur public
sénat on va débriefer cette séance si on
va tout de suite recueillir les
premières réactions politiques et aller
en salle des conférences retrouver à
steve jourdain qui est avec françois
patriat
le patron des sénateurs la république en
marche
rd pays alors avant de retrouver steve
jourdan je vais d'abord présenter mes
invités en plateau j'accueille
aujourd'hui laurence rossignol bonjour
bonjour cette sénatrice socialiste de
l'oise et j'accueille également cédric
vial je voulais être sénateur les
républicains de savoie bonjour et
d'ailleurs je précise que vous êtes
également candidat aux élections
régionales en auvergne rhône-alpes donc
pour respecter les règles d'équité on va
afficher la liste de et moi dans l'oise
et vous êtes au départemental non
régional régional d'accord donc avant
tout cas pour cédric gueule on va
ajouter l on va afficher la liste de
toutes les listes candidates aux
régionales en auvergne rhône-alpes une
un bandeau qui va qui va s'afficher à
suivre dans cette émission
donc on va comme je disais on va
recueillir les premières réactions
politiques après cette séance de
questions d'actualité on va aller en
salle des conférences retrouver steve
jourdain qui est cette fois ci avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer
oui avec jean michel blanquer r bonjour
monsieur le ministre le baccalauréat
proches le première épreuve de
philosophie auront lieu le 17 juin les
syndicats en c1 souhaité
un baccalauréat en version contrôle
continu vous y étiez opposé dans quelles
conditions sanitaires et bien va se
dérouler ce baccalauréat 2021 aux
autorités y avait différentes positions
certains étaient pour le contrôle
continu d'autres pour le contrôle
terminal comme vous le savez on est
arrivé à une solution je crois qui est
d'équilibrer c'est à dire d'avoir la
possibilité d'avoir la meilleure des
deux notes pour les élèves et puis de
maintenir le grand oral qui va être un
moment très important et très innovant
pour les nos élèves non j'allais dire
les enfants de notre pays en tout cas
les élèves de terminale alors un
protocole sanitaire qui est un protocole
sanitaire pour un écrit s'agissant de la
philosophie donc avec une distanciation
et toute une série de mesures que auquel
nous sommes maintenant très habitué et
puis d'autre part ce grand oral avec
d'autres dispositions sanitaires mais
enfin celle qu'on connaît bien comme
notamment l'aération le port du masque
et ses premiers très confiant sur cet
aspect c'est la première édition de ce
grand oral à ce que vous redoutez des
couacs où vous dites aujourd'hui tout
est prêt il n'y a pas de quoi que
spécifique à redouter vous savez
l'organisation du baccalauréat est
toujours une grande mécanique
particulière elle est d'ailleurs plus
légère cette année que que d'habitude et
ce qui est important dans le vent toral
7 juillet les enjeux de contenu c'est à
dire qu'en ce moment même nos élèves se
préparent à s'exprimer a argumenté à
approfondir un sujet bref à acquérir des
compétences dont ils ont justement
besoin dans la vie qui va suivre
et pour moi c'est très important ça leur
permet aussi d'approfondir leur
enseignement de spécialité sont des
enseignements qu'ils ont choisie qui
correspondent à leur passion est donc
temps s'arrête à un bon moment pour eux
nous le voyons avec bienveillance pour
leur permettre de réussir le chemin qui
va suivre la phases la première phase de
parcours suis pas débuté la semaine
dernière il ya deux mots qui reviennent
parfois dans la bouche des élèves ces
incertitudes et inquiétudes notamment
face à certaines arbitraire certains qui
considèrent qu' un arbitraire dans le
processus de sélection qu'est ce que
vous leur répondez à ces élèves pour
deux vols
mais kyle parcours super temps est en
route maintenant bien entendu on entend
ce qu'ils peuvent avoir des
insatisfactions c'est normal il ya aussi
tous ceux qui ont une satisfaction de
leurs voeux et qui s'exprime moins
forcément pour les autres comme vous
savez il ya d'autres phases qui vont
venir qui leur permettront d'avoir
quelque chose puisque de toutes les
façons tout le monde est affecté à la
fin c'est l'engagement que savard et
écrit un épisode bien sûr c'est qu'ils
savent il ya des commissions rectorales
poursuivre cela enfin là on rentre dans
une deuxième phase qui doit permettre de
satisfaire l'immense majorité des élèves
jean michel blanquer ramasse redit
dernier vous avez annoncé à plusieurs
mesures pour clore le grenelle de
l'éducation beaucoup de professeurs
disent finalement tout ça pour ça
seulement un tiers des professeurs vont
avoir une réelle revalorisation
salariale cés s'en lasse lassen ne peut
faire ce commentaire parce que sur
général et maintenant nous sommes en
train de rentrer avec les organisations
syndicales dans le détail détail des
mesures particulières dont nous parlons
personne ne peut dire ça parce qu'on n'a
pas encore donné la répartition atteint
10 un tiers seulement des professeurs
c'est à cette année en 2021 c'est à dire
là à la fin du mois de mai seraient les
mêmes disait jusqu'à il ya deux semaines
que ça n'était pas vrai qu'on a les
revaloriser or justement effectivement
un tiers des professeurs c'est à dire
les tirs le plus jeune à une
revalorisation sur son bulletin de
salaire à la fin du mois n'est donc
c'est très concret les mêmes disent
maintenant mener ce n'est pas vrai que
rade nouveau augmentation 2022
car si il y en aura une tranche dans la
commande 30 100 euros alors justement
c'est cela que nous sommes en train de
travailler techniquement d'ici à la fin
du mois de juin nous devons regarder si
c'est plutôt les toujours les débuts de
carrière ou même les milieux de carrière
que nous valorisons mais le but à la fin
c'est de valoriser l'ensemble des
professeurs puisque nous nous sommes
inscrits dans une démarche pluri
annuelle dont l'objectif est très clair
franchir démarche chaque année ses 700
millions l'année prochaine c'était 400
millions cette année et je l'espère bien
la même chose des années suivantes pour
vraiment à être un pays qui paye bien
ses professeurs la crise sanitaire nous
a montré à quel point nous avions besoin
de l'école c'est pourquoi nous sommes le
pays qui les a maintenues ouvertes et ça
veut dire qu'on a besoin de nos
professeurs c'est à dire bien les
recruter bien les considérer est non
seulement bien les payer mais aussi bien
les accompagner en termes de mutation de
carrière pour tout simplement qui est du
bien-être au travail les professeurs et
du bien-être au travail des élèves
merci jean michel blanquer remercie
d'avoir et merci aux questions de public
sénat
merci beaucoup steve et et bien on va
d'ailleurs revenir en salle des
conférences puisque dans quelques
secondes à votre micro il y aura bruno
retailleau le patron des sénateurs
l'est républicain steve c'est à vous oui
avec bruno retailleau qui est en train
de s'installer à mon micro bonjour
monsieur retailleau la sphère pelletier
on va parler de ce qui ce qu'on appelle
ce qu'on doit appeler maintenant la
sphère pelletier guillaume pelletier qui
dit partager certaines convictions avec
monsieur ménard est ce que guillaume
pelletier encore sa place dans votre
partie la république un non mais moi je
pense qu'on ne va pas faire de cette
affaire comme vous dites guillaume
pelletier la sphère du siècle parce que
ça n'est pas ça du tout je pense moi et
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire vis-à-vis
de ma famille politique moi je pense
qu'on n'a pas besoin de se situer ni
vis-à-vis du rassemblement national de
monsieur ménard mais ni vis-à-vis de
monsieur macron mais si on veut se
situer par rapport à nous mêmes par
rapport à notre propre valeur nos
couleurs notre identité politique il
faut que on tranche une ligne politique
il faut qu'on ait une incarnation
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que toute cette affaire a montré une
fois de plus ce que je dis depuis des
mois il faut un grand chelem de
départage il faut trancher
alors je suis sur le fait mon sens quasi
non c'est la cacophonie vous voyez
précisément ce système de départage il a
été confié en quelques sortes à gérard
larcher il en est où ce système de
départage en saura plus la semaine
prochaine je pense que oui et je pense
voyez j'étais seule semaine prochaine
est seul il ya quelques mois à dire que
nous devions passer par cette étape
parce qu'à l'époque et pas plus
qu'aujourd'hui aucun candidat parmi nous
n'écrasez le match donc quand personne
n'est crasse de match il faut se tourner
vers nos électeurs il faut trancher par
le vote parce qu'on est tout simplement
en démocratie mais j'ajoute quelque
chose c'est que la primaire ce sera un
moment qui permettra à la droite et au
centre d'exister à nouveau aujourd'hui
on est diluée et parce que précisément
on assez dilution on est obligé de se
situer par rapport à tel ou tel nom je
pense que la primaire c'est ce qui
permettra vraiment de relever la tête et
de nous mettre en ordre de bataille
c'est ce qu'attendent les français qui
majoritairement aujourd'hui chez nous
sont hautement division en ce moment au
sein des républicains ya combien de
lignes politiques
vous savez quand on lit les interviews
des uns et des autres et ceux qui sont
présidentiable on s'aperçoit qu'en
réalité il ya une vraie famille
politique et qu'on n'est pas si éloignés
les uns des autres certes on a des
sensibilités des personnalités des
parcours mais très franchement si vous
vous adressez à des personnalités de ce
niveau là je pense que on est pas si
dispersé de ça et moi je suis pour que
la droite reconquête la totalité son
territoire au niveau économique la
liberté sociale aussi la générosité
régalien la sécurité l'identité
les deux sont culturelles sont pour moi
aussi importante il aura quand elles
auront lieu quand ces élections
on parle doute du mois d'août déjà n'en
a coûté dont je pense que ce qui est
sérieux si on veut organiser un vrai
processus c'est la rentrée octobre sans
doute 9 ans parce que je trouve qu'on a
perdu beaucoup beaucoup de temps si on
m'avait écouté à la il ya pratiquement
un an tout cas au mois de septembre
dernier on aurait avancé on se
consacrerait aujourd'hui évidemment aux
élections régionales et départementales
et on aurait été prêt à commencer dès le
mois de juillet et on aurait un scénario
défini alors y'en a qui partent à tence
emmanuel macron qui entame son tour de
france vous allez aussi vous faire un
tour de france pour aller au contact des
français
non mais bien sûr et et on y est tous
les jours au contact des français mais
je suis derrière christelle morançais
dans ma région qui est une excellente
président de région et donc voilà je
fais campagne à ses côtés je vois des
français mais on voit bien que lui est
en campagne et mal macron il est
d'ailleurs en campagne permanente
donc il faut que nous en ce mobilisme et
pour moi cette primaire là qui doit
permettre aussi de constituer l'équipe
de france c'est le moyen de se mobiliser
et de dire aux français que nous serons
là et on en reparlera merci beaucoup
bruno retailleau merci d'avoir répondu à
mes questions
merci steve pour ses réactions
politiques en selle des conférences on
va se diriger dans la tribune de presse
de l'hémicycle du sénat avec quentin
calmet qui a suivi avec attention cette
séance de questions d'actualité et
quentin il y avait plusieurs temps forts
autour de la réforme de la haute
fonction publique est exactement alex on
a vu cette course de relais sénatoriales
avec trois groupes politiques qui ont
enchaîné des questions comme cela en
cascade pour dénoncer effectivement la
réforme de la haute fonction publique un
sujet hautement d'actualité puisque je
vous le rappelle une ordonnance
réformant les grands corps de l'état a
été examinée voté en conseil des
ministres ce matin ce midi cette réforme
notamment elle remplace un l'ena l'école
nationale d'administration par un un
institut national du service public
alors cette réforme au sénat et bien le
scandalise la droite écoutez donc le
sénateur et l'ère gérard longuet qu'à
poser la première question votre
initiative et destructrice d'un des
piliers de la république sur le terrain
pourquoi parce que le corps préfectoral
et xix
de la compétence interministériel cela
ne s'improvise pas cela de le membre de
la durée et lorsqu'il y a duré il y as
carrière et donc statut donc la question
que je pose est d'une grande simplicité
ce corps est ouvert les préfets on peut
nommer n'importe qui d'ailleurs certains
gouvernements ne s'en sont pas privés
les sous-préfets sont ouverts ou de la
minorité d'énarques il y a une immense
majorité de magistrats des cadres de
préfectures des policiers des militaires
des et voilà un corps ouvert voilà un
élément de promotion voilà un truc qui
marche et votre solide et celle à
en l'air
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'ai un long gain qui a été
longuement applaudie par la droite mais
aussi par certains sénateurs de la
gauche alors le premier ministre a
répondu à ce sénateur de droite il a
défendu l'idée d'une mobilité entre les
différents corps de la haute fonction
publique écouter jean castex
je n'ai jamais dit je commence par là
vous avez débuté que je voulais
supprimer les préfets sous-préfets
jamais je veux au contraire les
renforcer et conforter
vous avez parlé des sous-préfets dans la
plupart d'entre eux plupart d'entre eux
les deux tiers ils sont déjà et depuis
longtemps dans la réforme que nous
voulons faire les deux tiers en question
sont des administrateurs civils comme
précis détachés dans le corps des sous
préfets alors je vous le disais ce sont
au total trois groupes politiques qui
ont posé des questions sur ce sujet qui
ont enchaîné leurs questions et le
troisième c'était est le groupe
socialiste une question de jean-pierre
sueur lui il est scandalisé par
l'utilisation d'une ordonnance pour
mettre en place cette réforme ça
signifie qu'il n'y en a pas d'examen au
parlement comme on fait sur un projet de
loi par exemple écouter le sénateur ps
du loiret il est inconcevable qu'on
fasse cela sans que le parlement puisse
s'exprimer
ce n'est pas acceptable madame la
ministre tout cela madame n'est pas
sérieux et n'est pas conforme à l'esprit
les républicains merci
vous venez de le voir monsieur sur qui a
été aussi applaudi par des sénateurs de
droite ça montre qu'il ya et bien un
large consensus gauche droite pour
dénoncer cette réforme alex merci
beaucoup
quentin pour ce résumé laurence
rossignol est ce qu'on est en train de
détruire l'un des piliers de la
république avec cette suppression du
statut de préfet alors peut-être
il faut expliquer un peu ce qui est en
jeu parce que je suis pas sûr que les
français aient un peu de garde soient
tous immédiatement mobilisés par la
réforme sur les corps préfectoral
il faut savoir que moi je suis élu local
depuis plus de 20 ans et le préfet est
un interlocuteur constants pourquoi
c'est un interlocuteur constant est
important parce que tout ce que j'ai
connu et ça tourne souvent les préfets
sont avant tout des représentants de
l'état bien sûr il applique la politique
du gouvernement c'est bien normal mais
il représente l'état c'est à dire que
nous avons en face de nous des
interlocuteurs qui sont des
interlocuteurs qui sont avant tout au
service de la république oreilles qui
appliquent les recommandations et les
consignes de leur gouvernement ce que
vous le gouvernement c'est pas très
compliqué il ne veut plus d'eux préfet
un dépôt représentant la république
il veut des préfets à sa botte et en la
matière m nl macro est en train de
préparer son éventuel second quinquennat
cirque il veut des préfets qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient les représentants de la
république en marche dans les
départements et ça change beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de choses parce que si
les préfets sont respectés comme ils le
sont par les élus par les citoyens par
les corps intermédiaires c'est parce
qu'ils sont républicains ça veut dire
juste et impartiaux et demain nous
aurions si gouvernement va au bout de
cette réforme des préfets partiaux des
préfets aux ordres d'un pouvoir
politique et non pas des préfets au
service de la république c'est une
énorme réforme
safa l'air comme ça et c'est technique
mais c'est une réforme qui bouleverse
profondément l'esprit républicain
alors quand on pense qu'on sort de
plusieurs semaines de débats sur la
république la laïcité etc etc
ce gouvernement a le mot république à la
bouche en permanence on s'aperçoit qu'à
nîmes
ce fossé entre ce qu'il raconte sur la
république et la manière dont il veut
s'accaparer cédric béal vous pensez
aussi que c'est un coût qui est porté à
la neutralité du préfet c'est un risque
en tous les cas le risque même rossignol
rappelait est réel je pense que c'est
pas la seule
la seule question qui est posée mais au
delà de la question du statut il ya la
question du rôle du préfet je suis pas
très conservateur sur ce point là s'il
faut changer les choses qu'on les change
je pense que là aussi il faut être
honnête un certain nombre de problèmes
qui étaient posées dans le corps
préfectoral avec un sérum de préfet hors
cadre dont on sait pas trop pourquoi la
république continue à les rémunérer
il ya effectivement au risque de passer
de la loyauté de que le préfet doit aux
gouvernements un régime d'allégeance
kiné qui n'est pas bon il ya aussi la
cas de la question jeudi du rôle qu est
ce qu on veut faire du préfet et on
règle d'abord le question du statut à
vendre et les régler la question du rôle
j'entends par là aujourd'hui le
l'interlocuteur de l'état on parle
beaucoup du couple préfets préfets
maires mots si j'étais élu pendant une
vingtaine d'années
dans mon département aujourd'hui on
l'entend dans les discours on n'a jamais
vu aujourd'hui 1 et l'état hôte ils
centralisaient qu'ils les ont indiqué
qu'il a été
et quand tu l'as dans la période
qu'ovide par exemple la seule
responsabilité qui reste aux préfets
c'est décider si le port du masque dans
le département les deux préfets qu'il ya
quinze jours ont décidé de prendre une
décision pour pour alléger cette mesure
ont été rappelés à l'ordre par le
gouvernement
donc ils font la question c'est quel
rôle redonne au préfet je pense que il
faut on a des administrations
aujourd'hui qui lui échappe désert la rs
lagence des territoires etc ont créé des
agences qui échappent au contrôle du
préfet et on donne au préfet par contre
des moyens sans contrôle démocratique je
pense notamment au moyen de type dut r
s'il se dire des subventions que l'état
attribue aux communes on a enlevé ses
moyens aux communes pour les donner aux
pros à l'état mais c'est aujourd'hui un
homme qui seul sans contrôle
démocratique distribuer les subventions
des fois plus importante que le
département lui-même sur sur le
département
et ça ça pose aussi problème si les
préfets deviennent des collectivités
sans contrôle démocratique ça pose
problème
je pense qu'il faut renforcer le rôle du
préfet leur donner des moyens
de l'état et donc qu' un contrôle aussi
qui passe soit par le statut et sa
nomination comme le 10ème à la mentionne
j'adhère totalement soit par un contrôle
démocratique
laurence rossignol comme évoluer ce rôle
du préfet qui a été primordiale il faut
le rappeler pendant la crise sanitaire
avec le fameux couple préfet maire je
sais pas jouer autre chose sur cette
ordonnance qui a été adopté ce matin en
conseil des ministres ce n'est pas
simplement une ordonnance sur le corps
préfectoral cette ordonnance sur
l'ensemble de la haute fonction publique
et dans la cible du gouvernement il ya
une autre famille j'ai envie de dire de
hauts fonctionnaires c'est les corps
d'inspection qui sont sud kivu qui sont
appelées à disparaître alors évidemment
quand on a pas quand on n'en a pas
l'usagé
on ne sait pas forcément à quoi servent
ces corps d'inspection mais moi j'ai été
dans le ministre dans le pool des
affaires sociales où il ya l'influent
général des affaires sociales je peux
vous dire que les corps d'inspection
nous servent particulièrement à faire
des enquêtes à défricher le terrain à
aller voir pas en matière de protection
de l'enfance quand on a vu plusieurs
reportages qui indiquait que les enfants
étaient pas tous bien traité dans tous
les établissements
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on est
ministre on demande à l'inspection
générale de faire une enquête sur l'état
de la protection de l'enfance en france
parce que ses inspecteurs généraux ils
sont indépendants
ils remettent le rapport au ministre le
ministre ensuite a le choix de publier
ou non mais ils sont indépendants dans
ce qu'ils écrivent
et on a besoin de hauts fonctionnaires
c'est un de gens dévoués la république
mais indépendant des pouvoirs politiques
on a besoin leurs capacités expertise de
leur capacité d analyse et c'est
indispensable
et là j'ai compris qu'ils allaient
disparaître mais l'on sait pourquoi on
va disparaître le gouvernement a déjà eu
recours à plusieurs reprises à des
cabinets de conseil privé et donc demain
à la pesse des hauts fonctionnaires et
de leur rôle de conseil de l'état d'
expertise vous aurez des cabinets privés
qui vendront de la prestation au bout à
un ministre ou au gouvernement à la
place des hauts fonctionnaires et c'est
très grave
donc ce à quoi on assiste en fait c'est
une privatisation d'une partie de l'état
est une
aux ordres d'une autre partie de l'état
et ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on va
redonner aux français le goût de la
chose publique qui est aujourd'hui déjà
un peu affaibli mais je voudrais qu'on
parle d'un autre temps fort de ces
questions d'actualité du gouvernement
gouvernement il concerne les biens à la
montée du rassemblement national
notamment dans les sondages al'approche
des élections régionales et
départementales et le président de votre
groupe
laurence rossignol le groupe socialiste
patrick kanner a posé une question au
premier ministre sur ce sujet on va
l'écouter vous jouer une partition
dangereuse qui peut s'avérer tragiques
pour notre pays en explosant le paysage
démocratique en promouvant l'ambiguïté
du en même temps en espérant la
disparition de la gauche est maintenant
de la droite aujourd'hui le danger est à
nos portes
l'extrême droite comme dans d'autres
pays européens peut prendre le pouvoir
sans violence dans moins d'un dans le
deuxième tour de la présidentielle sera
passée vous ne pourrez pas dire que vous
ne saviez pas mathieu premier nice
cédric vial est ce que comme le dit
patrick kanner le gouvernement une forme
de responsabilité dans la montée du
rassemblement national en ce moment
l'action du gouvernement probablement
comme l'action du parti socialiste aussi
à une certaine époque et probablement
que certains ont voulu jouer aussi avec
cette montée pour des intérêts qui est
qui qui sont politiques mais mais je
pense que l
enfin j'ai trouvé la question maladroite
disons je pense que c'est pas un député
comme ce n'est pas au gouvernement de
demander des comptes sur la montée d'un
parti politique on doit s'interroger
plus tôt sur les raisons de cette montée
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
un vrai problème avec la crédibilité de
l'action publique et de la politique de
manière générale et là on est quelque
part tous responsables le vote front
national
aujourd'hui il a plusieurs failles il a
plusieurs facteurs le déclassement d'un
certain nombre de territoires d'un
décrochage entre ceux qui ont réussi
dans la mondialisation libéralisation et
ceux qui s'en sentent les victimes ou
qui s'en sentent déclassé mais c'est
avant tout un vote de mécontentement
un vote de mécontentement qui qui est
avant tout un vote contre la classe
politique c'est un vote politique contre
la classe politique parce que les gens
n'y croient plus et je pense que le
meilleur remède contre le front national
c'est de redonner espoir en tout cas de
redonner confiance en la parole publique
donc là en l'occurrence effectivement le
gouvernement a un rôle à jouer
si on arrivait à lui faire un peu plus
confiance peut-être que le front
national baisserait mais c'est le cas
aussi de tous les partis politiques qui
se pose en alternative
je pense que l'enjeu numéro 1 si on veut
faire baisser le vote contestataire et
votent front national c'est qu'il faut
redonner confiance aux gens dans la
politique
laurence rossignol skis emmanuel macron
a vraiment intérêt à faire baisser le
rassemblement national dans les sondages
au cas où on est dans une dans une
séquence qui est dangereuse parce qu'on
a deux candidats jon côté marine le pen
de l'autre emmanuel macron qui sont qui
ont un intérêt commun c'est que l'autre
soit candidat emmanuel macron et le
meilleur adversaire de marine le pen
c'est celui qui lui permet le plus
facilement de d'espérer un bon score de
deuxième tour sur la base du bilan du
gouvernement et des personnalités des
manuels macron qui n'est pas convaincu
ok une majorité de français n'adhèrent
pas et de notre côté emmanuel macron un
intérêt aussi à voir marine le pen en
face de lui parce que c'est la candidate
qui peut lui permettre d'espérer au nom
du barrage à l'extrême droite récupérer
des voix de gens qui ne se reconnaissent
nullement ni dans le sable politique
dans sa manière d'agir
in an et stratégies ce gouvernement donc
ce sont deux
d'une fratrie et demi c'est d'une
fratrie et demi aux intérêts liés donc
l'un et l'autre se font en permanence à
courte échelle est en fait la question
de patrick kanner moi je la comprends
bien ce qu'il a voulu dire au
gouvernement c'est que leur stratégie
politique depuis 2010 est qui consiste à
pulvériser tout le paysage politique
autour d'eux à dire avec en même temps
avoir détruit la gauche vouloir détruire
la droite et vouloir qu'il n'y en fin de
compte plus rien entre le rassemblement
national et emmanuel macron est une
stratégie extrêmement dangereuse parce
que dans un pays comme la france on a
besoin à un moment donné de rassembler
et emmanuel macron ne crée pas les
conditions d'un quelconque rassemblement
donc il va nous appeler s'ils et au
deuxième tour avec marine le pen l'année
prochaine les uns et les autres à faire
barrage au front national
mais on ne pourra ce sera difficile
d'aller chercher les électeurs les
bonnes comme les nôtres d'ailleurs ce
sera difficile à aller chercher
parce que ce gouvernement ne sera à la
fois jugés responsables de ce qui arrive
même à quoi on aura beau jeu de dire
qu'avant lui il ya déjà eu le front
national au deuxième tour mais il va
consister à cette étape il montre
considérablement et c'est la première
fois qu'on se pose à coeur de savoir
dans quelle zone elle exactement autour
de 50
donc ce qu'on a voulu dire c'est que à
force de jouer la carte de la
destruction de tout le paysage autour de
vous un moment donné vous êtes bien seul
sur ce paysage et se rappeler c'est pas
la peine de nous mettre la pression
comme ils ont déjà commencé à le faire
sarrail voilà si je peux me permettre
faut faire attention c'est en jouant
avec le feu que souvent se brûle et et
la stratégie d' emmanuel macron que vous
décriviez peut-être qu'effectivement
c'est celle là il risque de se la
prendre comme ce sera peut-être celle là
la quatrième vague qui va se prendre de
plein fouet comme à une époque le parti
socialiste a voulu jouer avec la montée
du front national
est ce les prix aussi en 2002
de plein fouet il faut faire attention à
ça et deuxièmement ce que je rappelais
tout à l'heure dans le jeu politique ce
qui est ce qui moi me gêne de plus en
plus c'est le jeu c'est doux c'est pas
un jeu on essaie de faire monter les uns
envers les autres je pense que là la
vraie réponse qu'il faut qu'on apporte
s'est aussi appuyé sur la politique plus
que sur le jeu redonner confiance dans
la parole la parole politique redonner
confiance aux gens ça passe par c'est ce
qu'on dit aussi tout à l'heure sur les
formes de lutte a redonné du pouvoir à
l'état et à ses préfets redonner du
pouvoir aux politiques notamment sur sur
le terrain est l'heureux et redonner de
la confiance dans les politiques aux
gens ils votent contre le système parce
qu'ils considèrent que le système ne
peut plus rien changer pour eux voilà il
faut changer ça un jeu comme vous dites
avec le feu du côté des républicains
quand on en entend est bien le numéro de
votre parti guillaume pelletier qui se
dit assez proche de robert ménard qui
est lui proche du rassemblement national
alors un où je suis plus dans ce parti
que vous décrivez je suggère élus sans
étiquette je suis rattaché à ce groupe
je suis un gaulliste et je me cache pas
des amendes qui doit mais je justement
j'ai quitté ce jeu des partis et il
parce que je ne me reconnais plus après
honnêtement enfin que plus guillaume
pelletier soit proche des idées du front
national
c'est un scoop pour personne enfin il en
est issu il en vient donc qu'il a envie
d'y retourner
c'est nous ou pas il le décidera mais je
pense que là vraiment né dans la petite
stratégie on retire une phrase par
rapport à une autre
je pense que ça ne grandit pas le débat
politique et qu'il faut s'écarter
vraiment de de catégoriser les gens par
rapport à des petites phrases lens on
signalait aussi ce climat d'insécurité
qui peut être à l'origine de la montée
du rassemblement national
écoutez les causes de la montée de
rassembler nationale elles sont diverses
on verra dans l'élection régionale sera
intéressant de comparer les scores du
front national en voix par rapport à
leur score précédent
est-ce qu'ils auront tant que ça
augmente et envoie ou est ce qu'ils
auront augmenté en pourcentage du fait
d'un désintérêt de nombreux français à
l'égard des élections régionales ce
n'est pas une chose qu'on peut faire
48 % avec le même nombre de voix que la
fois d'avant on avait fait 32 mais comme
les autres sont pas venus voter ça fait
monter le pourcentage je pense qu'il
faut quand même faire attention deux
choses d'abord et une banalisation des
idées du front national
les idées d'extrême droite on les entend
ces deux espèces de bruit de fond on a
des chaînes de télé qui sont totalement
consacré pour ceux qui sont inquiets
mais les chaînes de télé américaines
on alloue foxnews en france aujourd'hui
il ya effectivement celle et l air un
problème
guillaume pelletier deux problèmes le
premier c'est quand il nommé numéro 2
parce que comme vous avez raison il ya
pas de surprise sur youm pelletier il en
vient il n'a jamais caché et pris la
deuxième c'est que normalement il
devrait quand même ne pas paraître très
présent au prochain bureau national ont
normalement dans un parti politique qui
est pas trop temps qui tanguent pas trop
on se débarrasse de quelqu'un qui donne
l'impression d'avoir autant d'affinités
à l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur surtout
par des affinités sont extrêmement rares
on verra ce que décident les
républicains en tout cas on va retourner
on va retourner dans la tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle du sénat retrouver
quand un calme et avec un autre temps
fort quentin de cette séance de
questions d'actualité qui concernent des
violences de policiers contre les
parlementaires
oui tout à fait c'est effectivement un
des moments forts c'est lorsque le
président du groupe écologiste au sénat
guillaume gontard a interrogé le premier
ministre sur effectivement un événement
qui a eu lieu jeudi et on va revoir des
images puisque il ya une vidéo qui
devenu assez virale où on voit notamment
le sénateur joël labbé sénateur
écologiste du morbihan avec à côté de
lui les députés elle est fille qui
s'appelle bénédicte taurine être
bousculés par des policiers a
effectivement et bien
à ce moment là le le président du groupe
écologiste a dénoncé des faits
inacceptables et bien je vous propose
d'écouter la réponse de jean castex ce
premier ministre jamais une action d'un
syndicat majoritaire pourtant rarement
déclarée en préfecture et je ne compte
pas les les policiers blessés n'a fait
l'objet d'une répression aussi violente
et vous me l'accorderez après les gilet
jaune
les journalistes les avocats les
médecins et tant d'autres la répression
violente du mouvement social a atteint
un nouveau paroxysme plus personne
n'était pas renié ni les agriculteurs ni
même les représentants du peuple au
comprends que vous vouliez supprimer les
preuves avec le funeste et heureusement
mort né article 24 est donc le premier
ministre a répondu à guillaume gontard
en disant que la manifestation n'était
pas autorisée que deux policiers avaient
été blessés ecoutez jean castex 6 ha bon
endroit
les images dont vous parlez on ne plus
choquer et qu'elles sont regrettables
je rappelle également au sénat que dans
cette affaire
deux policiers ont été blessés et l'un a
subi des jets de pierres qui ont conduit
à son transport à l'hôpital
donc tout cela n'est pas normal tout
cela monsieur le présent n'est pas
normal il y a eu il y a eu des attitudes
qui sont condamnables
j'en profite chaque pour appeler chacun
au calme et à ses responsabilités en
tout cas ce qu'on a compris et bien de
lapins de l'écologiste guillaume gontard
sais que ce qui s'est passé je dis bien
c'est une dérive plus linge de violence
dans la société en ce moment et c'est ça
qu'il a aussi voulu dénoncer alex merci
beaucoup quand ans cédric vial est ce
que vous avez été choqué par ces images
de parlementaires bousculé par la police
honnêtement non s'est passé c'est pas
agréable après faut quand on parle de
violence oui on a une société qui est de
plus en plus violentes voire hyper
violente quand on dit que c'était à une
répression d'une violence qu'on a jamais
vu je pense qu'il faut on se gargarise
un petit peu de mots relativiser selon
louis forzy faut relativiser
je pense que c'est aussi soit une
attitude de l'extrême gauche de créer un
événement pour pouvoir après sow s'en
plaindre un incident par exemple pour
pouvoir s'en plaindre moi j'ai pas été
choqué je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
j'étais pas dans la discussion
je pense effectivement qu'il l'aimait
torts sont partagés probablement que le
policier aurait peut-être pu s'y prendre
autrement probablement que que notre
collègue aurait dû s'y prendre
différemment aussi donc c'est
regrettable mais je ne suis pas choqué
laurence rossignol
il faut relativiser ces images moi je
trouve ça très instructif parce que
depuis effectivement un moment on a des
manifestations on voit la violence d'un
certain nombre d'éléments extérieurs ou
de cassan la manifestation et on voit la
violence de la police qui s'abat parfois
de manière assez générales sur les
manifestants et pas sur les plus
violents et donc c'est pas toujours
laissé pas toujours ceux qui
mériteraient m'ont pris dans les
manifestations et là c'est flagrant
on a deux parlementaires dont un dont
une qui est avec l'écharpé tricolore
donc le policier peut pas dire qu'il n'a
pas vu que c'était une parlementaire
et puis l'abbé qu'on connaît tous notre
collègue écologiste qui est quand même
un homme tranquille et en fait il
n'était ni le premier ministre dit eu
deux policiers blessés mais n'ont pas
été blessés par pas à eux ils ont été
blessés par d'autres à côté un autre
moment et s'est abattue sur ces deux
parlementaires une brutalité
si on ne peut pas être violent soit une
brutalité qui n'est pas normal parce que
il ne mettait pas en cause la sécurité
de la manifestation
donc c'est ça le problème quoi dans les
manifs aujourd'hui c'est que au prétexte
qu'on a un groupe qui exercent des
violences dans la manifestation
la brutalité sa base sur tous les autres
et la finalité de tout ça c'est quoi
passer que les gens veulent tous aller
manifester
et donc tout le monde y trouve son
compte d'un certain point de vue les
gens veulent plus aller manifester en
famille ce qui faisait auparavant
parce que à tout le monde sait pas sur
qui va tomber à un moment donné la
charge de la police et là on a un
exemple je trouve terriblement
illustratif de ce qui peut se passer
dans une manifestation
et c'est pas bon pour les libertés
démocratiques et moi je suis très
attaché à la liberté de manifester ses
deux rivales c'est pas bon pour leur
manifester ce genre d'image honnêtement
on est abreuvé des d'image
manifestations violentes depuis un
certain nombre de mois
on en a vu des bien pires qui sont bien
pires pour le droit à manifester
oui je préfère d'ailleurs peut-être
qu'on parle de brutalité encore une fois
je sais pas comment ça s'est passé
c'est malheureux on a vu bien pire et
moi je je me mets aussi à la place des
des policiers qui depuis un an et demi
ont dû faire face à un certain nombre de
manifestations violentes ont dû faire
face à des agressions là où on peut
parler vraiment de violence qui sont
probablement aussi dans un état de
stress et donnèrent difficile alors ça
n'excuse pas peut-être un comportement
individuel mais je pense qu'il faut il
faut encore une fois raison garder et je
pense que la violence ces dernières
années elle était plutôt contre les
policiers qui encadraient manifestation
c'est la fin de ce débris ou des
questions d'actualité merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec moi sur ce plateau
alors concernant les élections
régionales pour bien faire les choses
dans les règles
cédric vial je précise pour finir que
vous êtes candidat sur une liste aux
élections régionales en auvergne
rhône-alpes
on va donc voir s'afficher toutes les
listes candidates aux régionales en
auvergne rhône-alpes et puis laurence
rossignol également vous êtes candidate
aux élections régionales dans la région
au de france et on va donc voir
s'afficher toutes les listes candidates
aux régionales dans les hauts de france
je précise que ce scrutin aura lieu les
20 et 27 juin prochains élections
régionales hexion départemental et
élections territoriales également voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi avec nous ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
dans un instant vous allez suivre
l'audition du pdg de carrefour alexandre
bompard qui a eu lieu ce matin au sénat
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
sur public sénat je propose en réponse
aux quelques demandes qui m'ont été
adressés